[Musique]
Anaïse Voigilis, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Euh oui, donc je suis Anis comme vous
venez de le dire. Je suis chercheuse
associée au sein de l'université deals
dans un laboratoire qui s'appelle le
CESAT qui est situé à Mulous où je
conduis des travaux sur les enjeux de la
réindustrialisation de la France et
comment on peut réindustrialiser que
j'ai débuté en 2014 et en parallèle je
suis consultante dans un cabinet de
conseil qui avait financé ma thèse dans
le cadre d'un contrecifre.
On vous connaissez pas. On vous a connu
grâce à un de vos tweets lorsque vous
étiez en commission. C'était ou
on c'était la commission d'enquête
parlementaire à l'Assemblée nationale
sur la désindustrialisation et la
réindustrialisation de la France.
En substance, qu'est-ce que ça disait ?
En substance euh on a été il y a eu tout
un panel d'auditionné et moi dans dans
mon panel, j'étais avec quatre autres
économistes et euh ce que je voulais
dire dans les 6 minutes qui nous sont
enfin 5 minutes, j'en ai pris six qui
nous sont impartis pour euh expliquer
comment on en arriver là et ce qu'on
peut faire, euh ben moi j'ai voulu
expliquer les les causes des
industrialisations et comment on pouvait
rebondir et avec un discours un peu
énergique parce que je pense qu'il est
l'heure de bouger un peu les lignes et
d'arrêter d'être des naïfs sur le sujet.
Alors ça tombe bien parce que ici on
peut prendre le temps.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe avec l'industrie
française ? Quel est le constat ? Où
est-ce qu'on va ? Quelles sont les
préconisations ? Quand on voit notre
gouvernement
et notre président de la République
faire de grandes incantations, par
exemple sur les masques,
alors que on continue à importer 97 % de
nos masques,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On se retrouve
complètement dépossédé. On a plus les
capacités. Est-ce que notre gouvernement
a un prisme de lecture moyen, long terme
ou simplement court terme, court
termiste ? Quel est votre constat ? Ah,
il y a il y a énormément de choses à
dire sur le sur le constat. Si je prends
l'exemple des masques, moi je me
souviens très bien, on est en en mars
euh et on a il y a eu tout un
cafouillage sur les masques parce qu'au
départ, il fallait emporter, pas
emporter, on savait pas trop. Et là, on
se rend compte que sur un certain nombre
de biens de première nécessité dans le
domaine médical, on a plus la capacité
de le produire en France. Donc on parle
des masques, mais il y avait aussi chez
des respirateurs, il y a eu les les
surblouses euh qui ont été absolument
dramatiques en terme d'image euh de ce
qu'est l'État français et de l'image que
ça projette dans l'inconscient de de nos
concitoyens. euh les surblouses quand
elles ont été remplacées dans certains
hôpitaux temporairement par des sacs
poubelles. Euh il y a eu la question sur
les principes actifs. On s'est rendu
compte que notre dépendance était très
profonde et là l'un des premiers appels
a été bah il faut refaire des masques en
France et il y a eu un une solidarité.
Beaucoup d'entreprises ont pu
reconvertir très rapidement leur chaînes
pour faire ça. Il même des des des gens
qui sont mis à coudre leur masque même
qui les ont distribué dans leur village
dans mes villes pour par esprit de
solidarité. Et la première chose que moi
je me suis dit pour l'histoire des
masques juste pour venir rapidement
dessus, c'est que on avait une usine en
Bretagne qui savait les faire.
On a le temps.
On a le temps. Je sais, on a le temps.
Défaut, je parle très très vite donc
jeis essayer de parler plus doucement.
Euh il y avait une usine qui s'avait les
faire en Bretagne et qui avait été
fermée 1 an ou 2 ans avant le début du
confinement. faute demande
et c'est exactement la remarque que moi
je fais à ce moment-là, c'est de dire
c'est bien de faire des masques en
France. Le problème c'est que on va en
train potentiellement de vouloir
réimplanter des usines qui le font. Si
on n pas de commande publique, ça sera
un vœux pieux. Et aujourd'hui, si je
suis sûre, j'ai pas les chiffres exacts
en tête. Si je regarde la commande
publique française et je peux même
donner un exemple, je l'ai pas dans ma
poche. Frenchtech qui est plus ou moins
associé au gouvernement, les masques
viennent de Tunisie. Donc c'est-à-dire
que même le gouvernement français et les
pouvoirs publics français ne prennent
pas forcément des masques qui sont faits
en France. Donc dans la
réindustrialisation, il y a un sujet clé
qui va être la demande sur lequel on
reviendra très certainement plus tard.
ou le patriotisme.
Ah, c'est deux choses. Je pense qu'il il
y a un sujet de de patriotisme. Après,
le jusqu'où va le patriotisme ? Est-ce
qu'on est obligé de tout faire en France
et de de tout acheter en France ? Je ne
suis pas sûre. En tout cas, il y a un
vrai effort de solidarité et euh
peut-être que les masques ne sont pas la
priorité des priorités ont une capacité
de produire en France puisqu'on voit
qu'on peut rapidement refaire des
productions françaises. Mais il y a une
chose est sûre, c'est que si on veut une
industrie puissante en France, ça va
d'abord passer par une demande française
et que cette demande, elle est triple.
Elle est à la fois la demande à travers
les achats publics. Donc ça va être
l'évolution euh des stratégies des
acheteurs publics. Euh et euh c'est des
demandes conséquences qui des moyens
conséquences à la fois l'échelle locale,
l'échelle régionale, tous les EPCI,
c'est euh c'est l'État, les
administrations et cetera. Le deuxième
pilier de la demande c'est tout ce qu'on
va voir en B2B. Donc les entreprises
B2B, il faut expliquer parce que tout le
monde n'est pas familier avec ce
vocabulaire. Donc c'est l'achat d'une
entreprise à une autre entreprise et
donc c'est pas des achats enfin c'est
pas un consommateur qui achète à une
entreprise. Raisonne, je le dis
simplement.
Là aussi les entreprises ont un rôle à
jouer. C'est-à-dire que la
réindustrialisation, elle sera vraiment
puissante si on ne se contente pas
d'avoir des activités d'assemblage en
France comme on peut l'avoir dans un
certain nombre de secteurs, les
batteries, le vélo et bien d'autres.
c'est si on arrive à reconstituer des
écosystèmes. Et pour reconstituer des
écosystèmes, il faut structurer une
demande, c'est-à-dire que les
entreprises doivent chercher à
s'approvisionner en premier lieu à
proximité de leur lieu de fabrication
et et et au moins au périmètre national,
voire au périmètre européen, mais cesser
de faire venir des choses de l'autre
bout du monde. Malheureusement, il y a
un certain nombre de choses qu'on ne
sait plus faire en France et il y a des
choses notamment on est très en retard
sur l'électronique et sur d'autres
choses. Et puis il y a aussi parfois une
méconnaissance de ce qu'on sait faire en
France puisquon a des TPE PME qui font
plein de choses mais qui n'ont pas
forcément de site internet qui ne
communique pas et donc s'il y a pas un
moment aussi un effort pour valoriser ce
qui se fait alors ça risque d'être en
plus compliqué que ça ne l'est déjà.
Mais en tout cas il y a aussi un effort
des entreprises de revoir leur stratégie
d'approvisionnement d'avoir une approche
qui ne soit pas uniquement une approche
centrée sur le prix mais plutôt une
approche sur les coûts complets
d'acquisition. C'est-à-dire, regardez,
j'ai mon prix d'achat, mais j'ai ma
question de prix de stock, euh de
surstock aussi parce que quand j'achète
à l'autre roupe du monde, j'ai le stock
que j'ai présentement, j'ai le stock qui
est en transit dans les bateaux et j'ai
le stock qui est en train d'être produit
dans les usines. Et donc avec aussi et
bien plus de choses que je jette parce
que je ne les écoule pas, soit pour mes
produire mes mes biens à moi, soit parce
que je je ne les les vends pas. Donc
c'est ces réflexions qu'il faut avoir.
Et on dit pas aux entreprises françaises
d'acheter tout de suite 100 % français.
C'est juste déjà si tout le monde fait
un effort de passer de par exemple de 5
à 10 d'augmenter de 5 à 10 % son
approvisionnement français, alors on va
pouvoir commencer à avoir une
réindustrialisation vraiment durable. Et
le troisième pilier qui est un pilier
important, c'est l'acte de consommation
individuelle. C'est-à-dire que la
désindustrialisation, c'est aussi, c'est
difficile à dire parce que j'entends
qu'il y a des questions de pouvoir
d'achat, il y a il y a plein de choses,
mais c'est aussi nos choix individuels.
C'est-à-dire quand je fais le choix
d'acheter par exemple un tournevis qui
est made in China plutôt qu'un tournevis
plus cher en France, parce que je dis
bah mon usage en fait il est euh trois
fois par an, donc j'ai pas besoin de
mettre plus cher dans dans un truc
peut-être plus solide, et bien je
condamne aussi des emplois en France. Ce
qu'il faut se dire, c'est que tous nos
actes ont des conséquences sur
l'écosystème. Tous nos choix ont des
conséquences sur ce qui va se passer
dans notre pays ou dans le monde. Et
c'est très dur parce que on on se dit
oui, en fait on a tendance à se
dresponsabiliser. Or, on a aussi une
responsabilité individuelle et on a
aussi une capacité par nos choix à
influencer les entreprises par une
question de rapport de force. Demain,
tout le monde se met à boycotter
quelqu'un qui fait fabriquer quelque
chose en Chine parce que on estime que
c'est des produits qui ne respectent pas
qui détruisent l'environnement, qui ne
respecte pas les standards sociaux et
cetera. Alors, il y a quand même une
capacité des consommateurs à faire
revoir les stratégies des des
entreprises. Euh et l'autre chose qu'il
faut qu'il faut dire, c'est que on est
aujourd'hui beaucoup dans une société
qui surconsomme et je crois qu'il y a à
travers ces réflexions de consommer plus
français, il y a aussi une plus locale,
on va dire peut-être pas plus français
mais plus local parce que je pense que
c'est
on peut dire plus français. français,
mais c'est aussi les Italiens vont se
dire je vais consommer plus italien, les
Allemands, je vais consommer plus
allemands. L'enjeu, c'est une
consommation aussi plus responsable. Et
donc c'est euh raisonner au lieu de
raisonner pour le consommateur en en
coût d'achat, c'est en coût d'usage. Se
dire peut-être que j'achète un t-shirt 5
€ et donc je peux en acheter 10, sauf
qu'en fait les 10 ils vont durer un an
et que je vais en acheter un plus cher
qui sera euh fait localement avec des
ressources locales mais qui va durer
plus longtemps. Donc si si au final le
coût d'usage va montrer que bah la
question du pouvoir d'achat, elle peut
peut-être être aussi relativisée. Et et
la chose qu'il faut se dire, c'est que
le moins cher dans lequel on est, la
l'économie du low cost, l'économie
fast fashion,
fast fashion, hard discount et cetera,
c'est pas parce que c'est c'est le moins
cher, c'est c'est une illusion. le moins
cher a un coût très cher. Il a un coût
individuel sur le temps long parce que
du coup on va acheter plus mais il a un
coût pour la société qui est énorme.
C'estàd que en en choisissant de
consommer
du moins cher des produits pas français,
on a aussi contribué à la
désindustrialisation.
Après, si on peut revenir aussi,
pourquoi on s'est désindustrialisé ?
Peut-être euh la désindustrialisation,
je crois qu'il faut le dire avec une
forme de sévérité, de lucidité.
C'est un pays qui a abandonné son
industrie.
C'est un pays, ce sont des élites. Ce
sont des élites qui ont considéré qu'à
un moment l'industrie n'avait plus sa
place dans une économie dite moderne,
économie post-industrielle.
C'est quoi les élites ?
Alors, les élites, qu'est-ce qu'on met
derrière les élites ? une très bonne
question puisque c'est un peu un tarte à
la crème tout le monde l'utilise mais je
veux dire ce sont ceux qui avaient la
capacité de décider donc les
responsables politiques,
les autres les hautes administration
un certain nombre de dirigeants
d'entreprise euh des cabinets de conseil
qui ont aussi conseillé les entreprises
dans leur stratégie de
désindustrialisation.
C'est euh
je je j'en fais un bon tour et c'est
aussi peut-être les médias en véhiculant
ces discours et aussi
les agences de pub aussi peut-être
les agences de pub enfin il y a il y a
il y a une responsabilité qui est qui
est globale mais à un moment on a fait
le choix plus ou moins conscient je
pense qu'il y avait des choses qui
étaient de l'ordre du conscient et
pourquoi je dis conscient inconscient
c'estd qu'on s'est volontairement des
des détourner notre industrie. on est
passé de grandes ambitions industrielles
à des politiques d'accompagnement des
plans sociaux et de ralentissement euh
de de ces choix à partir du de la fin
des années 70 début des années 80. Et
pourquoi je dis que c'est aussi un non
choix ? C'est qu'on a les Allemands d'un
côté qui font le choix très ferme d'être
un pays industriel. les allemands, vous
avez euh euh une entente des grands
partis politiques sur le fait que c'est
un pays de production et que l'industrie
est le cœur du réacteur. Et vous avez à
côté un autre exemple qui est l'exemple
britannique
qui est de dire et bien on va devenir
plutôt une économie de service, une
place financière et cetera qui a un
autre choix qui a eu des conséquences
notamment sur les inégalités sur ils ont
essayé d'amoindrir les effets de la
désindustrialisation en attirant des
capitaux étrangers ce qui s'est avéré
être
un drame euh à plein d'égard puis qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de de pertes d'argent
public et nous on fait pas vraiment le
choix. On a un entre deux. on on n'est
plus une puissance industrielle parce
que on s'y est pas intéressé mais on on
l'a pas finalement à à choisi aussi
clairement que le Royaume-Uni et on
n'est pas devenu vraiment une économie
de service. Et et résultat, on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation, on peut
pas être totalement indépendant. Je vais
être il faut être lucide, il faut être
honnête, on ne sera jamais totalement
indépendant.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on a pas de matière
première.
pour des questions de matière première
on sera forcément dans une situation de
de dépendance pour une situation de
taille d'économie où on ne peut pas je
pense qu'on peut être indépendant à
l'échelle européenne, on ne peut pas
être indépendant à l'échelle nationale.
Mais nous notre drame c'est que on n'est
plus à l'échelle de l'indépendance
choisie la dépendance choisie. On est
dans la le la l'aire de l'indépendance
subie,
forcé
et et malheureusement euh 40 ans en
désindustrialisation, on n'y revient pas
en 2 ans et à l'effort d'une crise avec
quelques milliards. Surtout quand vos
voisins proches ou moins proches ont eu
des stratégies de maintenir une
industrie. Et ce que je voudrais dire
aussi là donc qui est très important à
mon avis qu'on dit assez peu, c'est
qu'il y a encore un mythe chez certains
de dire oui mais ce qui compte c'est la
valeur. on va se concentrer sur les
hautes technologies
parce que tout le discours de la
désindustrialisation c'était on se
concentre sur la m et la val de produire
le fait de faire n'est pas important
complètement sous-estimé l'importance
d'avoir des liens entre innovation et
site de production d'avoir les deux
proches comme on le trouve en Chine
comme on peut le trouver ailleurs. Ça
c'est une une chose. La deuxième chose
c'est qu'on se dit aujourd'hui on va se
positionner sur les biens de
technologie.
Mais les gars tout le monde a envie de
se positionner sur les biens de
technologie. Et vous croyez que la Chine
a envie de rester un pays atelier ?
Croyez que les les la Chine et les
Chinois avec la condescendance dont on
les traite, ils ont ils ont envie de ce
destin ? Mais non, ils investissent, ils
sont en train d'investir des milliards
avec des plans très précis, une
politique certainement très autoritaire
et qu'on peut critiquer et ça, il y a
pas de problème. Mais on est en train de
de de se mettre le doigt dans l'œil en
pensant qu'on va rattraper notre retard.
On a je sais pas si on est naïf ou si on
est encore dans une forme de
condescendance, mais euh il va il faut
vraiment prendre conscience de là où on
part, de là où on part et tout ce qu'on
a à faire et le fait que on peut pas le
faire seul. Et malheureusement euh nos
alliés ne sont pas si nombreux que ça
puisque au sein du sont peut-être pas
nos alliés d'ailleurs.
Alors ça dépend desquels on regarde. Si
on regarde les États-Unis, je pense que
chacun joue joue sa partition et et à
ses stratégies. Si on regarde à
l'échelle européenne, je pense que
aujourd'hui malheureusement la
construction européenne dans c'est très
dur hein parce que je le dis souvent, je
suis né en 9 mai donc je suis vraiment
né le jour de la fête de l'Europe, ça
s'onte pas. J'étais vraiment la
génération qui a été bercée avec l'idée
de l'Europe c'est l'avenir et cetera.
Génération Erasmus, tout ce que vous
voulez, tous les trucs tartes à la crème
et cetera. et euh et avec peut-être
parfois je je dis ça peut être critiqué
mais un sentiment d'être plus européen
que que français. Quand je regarde
l'état de la construction européenne,
dumping fiscal,
c'est qui exportera le mieux euh qui
attira mieux les activités de siège.
Dumping social, qu'est-ce que c'est
quand même très compliqué de travailler
quand vous avez des pays comme la
Bulgarie, vous êtes à 9 € de l'heure et
nous on a 38 € de l'heure ou
le Portugal
ou le Portugal euh plus proche mise en
concurrence des États aucune capacité à
parler d'une voie commune sur des choses
qui devraient être l'intérêt de de notre
du continent. réciprocité dans l'accès
au marché public, les Allemands disent
non. Contrôle les investissements
étrangers, on a un accord à minima.
Certes, ça existe mais c'est à minima.
taxe carbone aux frontières européennes,
on a pas d'accord aujourd'hui et je
pense que ça va être très difficile à
avoir. Donc on voit bien que quelque
chose qui aurait dû être fondé sur des
principes de solidarité au départ euh de
la construction européenne aujourd'hui
ça ne fonctionne ça ne fonctionne pas
et donc on se retrouve dans une
situation un peu de blocage.
Les élus nos nos délégués nos
représentants
quand vous abordez le sujet avec eux ils
sont quoi ? Ils sont dans l'expectatif,
ils sont à brasser de l'air, à brasser
de la fumée, à sculpter de l'air chaud.
Est-ce qu'il y en a certains qui
comprennent les menaces qui pèsent sur
notre industrie et les futures menaces ?
Est-ce qu'ils anticipent ? Est-ce qu'ils
ont un un prisme de lecture à moyen
terme minimum ou à long terme ? Est-ce
qu'ils sentent que on est au bord de la
falaise ou ou ça leur passe au-dessus de
la tête ?
Alors, c'est je crois qu'il y a déjà en
fonction des échelons, il y a des
euh des réactions de ces différentes. Je
trouve que dans les dans les
collectivités locales ou dans les
régions, on trouve des gens qui ont
beaucoup d'acuité sur ces sujets, qui
ont envie de faire des choses et en même
temps qui se retrouvent avec assez peu
de moyens
qui
vous pouvez trouver des des
vice-présidents de région, des des des
maires des choses comme ça, des maires
qui vont aussi qui peuvent être capables
de se mobiliser très fortement. sur des
sujets de fermeture d'usine qui ont vite
contribué à la revitalisation de le de
leur territoire et finalement qui ont
assez peu de moyens. Maintenant, si on
parle de ceux qu'on entend dans le débat
public,
euh
je vous alors je vous dire un truc très
sincère, je l'ai jamais dit moi j'ai
fait une teste qu'il y avait Arnaud
Montebourg au ministère du productif. On
lui passe le bonjour d'ailleurs.
On lui passe le bonjour au passage. Euh
je vais revenir un peu sur la jeunesse
de ma thèse. C'était en 2014, j'avis
beaucoup travaillé sur les milieux
d'extrême droite et j'avais pas envie de
faire une thèse sur l'extrême droite
parce que
le nom de la thèse ?
Alors ma thèse c'était les enjeux et les
déterminants de la réindustrialisation
de la France. Et avant, si vous voulez
tout savoir, j'ai fait un mémoire sur
les élections municipales à Marseille et
sur l'extrême droite parce qu' à ce
moment-là, l'extrême droite faisait de
bons scores avec notamment des premiers
sénateur Eren qui a été élu à Marseille,
Stéphane Ravier et euh et j'ai travaillé
sur le vote des personnes issues de
l'immigration pour le Rassemblement
national dans le sud. Enfin, je fais un
un certain nombre de de recherches
là-dessus, mais j'avais pas envie de
faire ma thèse parce que il y a un
aspect assez déprimant que que on le
rassemblement national en France, il y a
une sorte de de psychose nationale.
C'estd on en parle, on en parle beaucoup
mais finalement s'attelle pas vraiment à
ce qui pourrait remédier au votes. Et
c'est à ce moment-là, je commence à
travailler dans une dans une région au
cabinet d'un président de région.
C'était la région pas tout charante
hein, tout savoir exactement.
Exactement. Et euh
et euh c'est le moment où Arnaud
Montebourg sort du ministère du
redressement productif.
Alors sortir c'est bien grand mot.
Sortir euh bon il y a une une dém il
démissionne il démissionne mais sur
c'est un peu compliqué je je je
conseille à vos auditeurs de lire son
livre l'engagement. il raconte ça r
beaucoup mieux que moi.
Et nous, on conseille aussi d'écouter
son discours euh quand il part du
ministère
aussi. Et euh et euh et à ce moment-là,
moi je vois ce qui se passe à la région,
je vois beaucoup d'entreprises en
difficulté. Je je trouve qu'il y a des
difficultés à les accompagner, que les
régions ont pas forcément les outils et
je me dis mais je je de l'image hein qui
t'a qui t'a parlé 1hure et demi autant
que je sois totalement sincère comme ça
tout le je suis sous ma douche un matin
et je me dis au départ je voulais
travailler sur l'industrie. Je le savais
mais je voulais travailler sur
l'industrie israélienne et me dire mais
comment est-ce qu'un pays dans un
contexte aussi difficile arrive à avoir
une industrie aussi puissante ?
patriotisme,
le patriotisme, la diaspora, le fait de
mettre des moyens, de mettre des vrais
moyens et de de se fixer des cap euh
avec des indicateurs. On s'en reviendra
sur le le le moyen et le le long terme.
Et et je me dis c'est dommage parce que
j'avais la conviction que avec le départ
de d'Arnaud Montebourg et la fin du
ministère du redressement productif, la
question de la désindustrialisation,
elle est s la désindustrialisation, la
réindustrialisation, elle est sortie du
débat public. Et moi, je me suis dit
mais euh non, en fait, j'ai envie
d'écrire une thèse là-dessus, j'ai envie
de comprendre et j'ai envie de
comprendre en tant que citoyen, c'est
dire, j'ai envie aussi de proposer euh
des solutions. J'ai pas juste envie
d'être dans la contemplation. Je essayer
de trouver des voix pour pour y arriver.
Et quand j'ai commencé ma thèse, euh les
gens prenaient mais pour une dingue, une
anénieur qui s'intéresse à l'industrie,
qui en plus veut pas le localiser sur un
écosystème particulier, qui a envie
d'avoir une vision globale là-dessus en
considérant que l'industrie c'est une
question qui doit dépasser le cadre de
l'usine, qui touche à plein d'autres
plein d'autres secteurs et cetera. On
m'a on m'a on me r au nez. Les
entreprises me recevaient euh de manière
extrêmement gentille, mais les autres
euh voilà, elle est brave la petite,
mais euh
elle doit pas elle doit pas boire que du
thé le matin, il doit se passer d'autres
choses dans sa tête. Et en 2020,
vous étiez une femme, pas ingénieur ?
Pas pas parce que j'étais une femme et
pas ingénieur si je pense que ça
rajoutait au décor, mais c'était en 2014
parler de réindustrialisation, c'était
c'était fini. On était encore dans
l'idée de se dire l'industrie euh c'est
c'est c'est du passé.
Dire le le renouveau du discours sur
l'industrie en France, c'est mars 2020.
C'est la situation de dépendance dans
laquelle on est. Les débuts de
relocalisation, c'est mars 2020. Avant
mars 2020, on a moins de 200
relocalisations en France et plutôt sur
des PME.
C'est avant on on en parle très peu ou
quand on en parle, on n'y croit pas et
tout ce qui a été mis en place n'est pas
suffisant. Alors maintenant, si j'en
reviens sur la sincérité des gens, je
pense qu'un un un un un type comme
Arnaud Montebourg euh est vraiment
quelqu'un de convaincu, quelqu'un de
sincère. Il y a quelques autres élus qui
sont moins connus. Si on regarde du côté
des républicains, on a quelqu'un comme
Olivier Marlex qui est député euh des
Républicains, qui a notamment fait la
commission d'enquête sur l'affaire
Alstom G. Euh, on a quelqu'un comme lui,
on a des gens comme Marie- Noël Yenman
euh au Sénat, on a euh qui Non, elle est
pas communiste, elle est euh socialiste,
groupe socialiste et républicain. Euh on
on en a quelques-uns comme ça. On a euh
je pense que quelqu'un comme Gérard Leol
qui se lance la commission d'enquête
parlementaire là sur droit de tirage de
l'opposition à la à la à l'Assemblée
nationale et quelqu'un de sincère et je
pense même que dans la majorité
présidentielle, on a des gens qui
peuvent être convaincus par le sujet.
Maintenant, il y a deux choses. Il y a
être convaincu et se donner les moyens
de réussir. Il y a être convaincu et
poser le bon constat.
Ce qu'il faut quand même rappeler, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde parle tout
le monde parle industrialisation pour la
présidentielle. C'est un truc
extraordinaire. Ça va, on va parler
presque plus d'industrie que séc de
sécurité. Bien, on a
C'est peut-être bien.
C'est très bien. Moi, je m'en réjouis.
Je je ne peux On a on a tout le monde
tout le monde en parle. C'est c'est
c'est c'est top mais faut se poser un
peu un peu un moins les bonnes
questions. Et puis moi quand j'entends
certains en parler, je sais pas si je
ris tout court ou si je ris jaune. Mais
la désindustrialisation, il faut pas
oublier que le Parti socialiste, ils
étaient au pouvoir. Ils ont été au
pouvoir. Ils ont été au pouvoir sousant.
Ils ont été au pouvoir avec Hollande, il
y a eu aussi la période Jospin, ce qui
ne veut pas dire qu'ils n'ont rien fait,
mais ils ont quand même été au pouvoir.
La droite a été au pouvoir. Donc, on a
des gens qui aujourd'hui nous en parlent
qui disent "Oui, ce qui est fait, c'est
pas bien et cetera." Mais qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait quand vous étiez au
pouvoir ? Et si je l'allie à la question
environnementale, question
environnementale, on en parle aussi de
avec autant d'acépuis la crise, mais
c'est on ne pouvait pas l'ignorer. Les
rapports du JC, les rapports du club de
Rome commence à partir des années 70.
Donc là, on se retrouve dans une
situation où il faut avoir une vision de
long terme et en même temps, on est
vraiment dans un temps très court pour
faire des transformations qui vont être
extrêmement douloureuse.
Pour qui ?
Pour les citoyens, pour nos concitoyens
parce que ça va avoir un impact sur le
pouvoir d'achat. Je parle même pas des
questions de croissance ou de
décroissance. J'ai pas de religion sur
le sujet. Je suis pas économiste, j'ai
pas de compétence en à en à à à à à à à
à à trancher le débat. Mais ça va
forcément avoir des conséquences sur le
pouvoir d'achat. ça va avoir forcément
des compétences sur nos choix des
conséquences sur nos choix de vie. Donc
les citoyens, les entreprises, les
entreprises peuvent donner un des drames
qui sont en train de se produire et qui
font dire que l'industrie on s'imme pas
toujours là où il faudrait. Les
fonderies MBF, les fonderies du poitou
et et bien d'autres. Ne croyez pas qu'on
pouvait anticiper le sort de séponderie,
la conversion du thermique à
l'électrique ? Alors, je sais que ça
fait discours très énervés. On me dit
faut pas s'énerver. Alors, je vais pas
redire que j'ai 30 ans et quand on a 30
ans dans ce pays, on a envie de
s'énerver mais on a envie. C'est moi, je
veux dire, c'est mon avenir aussi. Ça
c'est c'est les gens qui prennent des
décisions aujourd'hui. Quand on sera en
2050 et quand ça sera pris + 3 degrés
dans la tête, je viens de discours un
peu décousu, vous m'excuserez, ils ne
seront plus là où ils seront en train de
sucrer des fraises.
Mais si j'ai des enfants maintenant, en
2050, ils auront 20 ans. Et c'est quelle
planète qu'on leur laisse ? C'est quelle
planète qu'on laisse aux générations
futures ? C'est quelle planète qu'on
laisse à la biodiversité ?
au aux gens qui aux animaux qui vivent
dans notre écosystème, à la faune, à la
flore, à tout ça, qu'est-ce qu'on laisse
? Laisser le proverbe.
Vous allez me l'a dit, vous allez me le
redire.
Après moi le déluge.
Après moi le déluge. Oui, exactement.
Mais c'est terrible. C'est terrible. Et
et ça aujourd'hui parce qu'on a un
manque de de de C'est pour ça que je dis
l'industrie, il faut la penser au-delà
des murs de l'usine et il faut la il
faut avoir un ministère qui ne soit pas
qu'un ministère de l'industrie. On ne
peut pas penser l'industrie sans penser
les questions d'infrastructure.
Quand on quand on parle euh de euh de
transition vers le véhicule électrique,
quand on parle de l'hydrogène qui prête
un débat en tant que tel parce qu'on
entend un peu tout et n'importe quoi, on
on sait qu'on va augmenter nos besoins
en électricité. Donc, on a besoin d'une
réponse sur les infrastructures. Est-ce
qu'on est capable de produire
l'extéctricité suffisante ? On a besoin
de penser en infrastructure de
transport, de transport de l'hydrogène,
mais aussi l'infrastructure de recharge.
Comment on va recharger les véhicules
électriques ? Vous avez vu qu'on a parta
en vacances, vous avez vu le nombre de
caisses qu'il y a sur une une aire de de
de d'autoroute avec deux bornes, trois
bornes dans les meilleurs des cas. Si on
anticipe pas tout ça, alors on va aller
on va encore on va encore buter et on n
plus à l'air des petits pas. la
gradiation en disant que tout le monde
allait suivre, on l'a fait pendant 30
ans, ça n'a pas marché. Donc maintenant,
il va falloir faire de la vraie
planification. Sinon, on va aller vers
des drames humains et des drames sociaux
euh type fonderie x 1000. Euh
on a besoin de penser les
infrastructures de transport, de
logistique. Plus je vais rapatrier des
unités de production sur le territoire
français et je le souhaite, plus je vais
augmenter mes besoins en fonciers avec
des vrais sujets d'artificialisation des
sols. Comment je les gère ? comment je
gère mes friches industrielles, comment
je peux les reconvertir et je reviendrai
après sur les principes de précaution
parce qu'il y a aussi des choses à dire
là-dessus. Je je vais augmenter mon mon
nombre de camions sur les routes et
personne n'envie ça. Personne n'envie
ça. Donc il va falloir penser à
développer du ferroviaire. On a la part
du ferroviaire, du frais de ferroviaire,
la moins développé d'Europe. Et donc ça
c'est des sujets d'infrastructure qu'il
faut penser avec la politique de
réindustrialisation tout comme le les
les ports et cetera. L'autre chose,
c'est le sujet des compétences.
Il va falloir accompagner les gens dans
la transformation.
On sait déjà que sur les métiers
traditionnels de de l'industrie, on est
en tension. Et ça, je crois que des
métiers qu'on a tellement déconsidérés,
que ça soit des des des métiers de de
d'ouvriers, de techniciens qualifiés et
cetera, on les a complètement
déconsidéré dans le débat public. Et en
plus avec tous les drames qu'on a dans
l'industrie, on s'étonne que plus
personne a envie d'aller y travailler.
Mais mais on a on a on a contribué
contribué à ça. Après, il y a tous les
les parcours de nos dirigeants et cetera
qui contribuent à à mon avis à à à créer
un rejet dans l'industrie. On a on a
tension sur les compétences actuelles,
tension sur les compétences futures
quand on parle d'industrie 4.0 et
cetera. Donc ça veut dire qu'on va
mettre une couche de soft beaucoup plus
importante dans les usines donc avec des
sujets d'algorithmie, donc des
compétences qui sont déjà en tension et
qui situent plutôt dans les métropoles
quand tout l'enjeu de la
réindustrialisation va être plutôt
d'aller placer les usines dans les
villes petites et moyennes pour les
effets d'entraînement de 1 à 3 à qu
emplois indirects. Quand on crée un
emploi direct dans l'industrie, on crée
trois à quatre emplois indirects.
Donc on a intérêt à localiser les usines
là. Mais donc ça ça revient mes sujets
d'infrastructure. On a le sujet de
l'environnement. On peut pas avoir une
stratégie nationale bacbone. Alors, on
parle de décarboner l'usine. Les usines,
je pense que c'est décarboner les
chaînes de valeur qui est beaucoup plus
important. On pour avoir une usine à
zéro émission de carbone. Si l'amont et
l'aval des des de la chaîne de valeur
est pourrie, c'est un peu de l'ordre de
du vœux pieux. Euh, on a les
un exemple un exemple par exemple pourri
en amont et en aval. Bah je sais pas si
je prends une usine
qui produirait je de des de alors de l'a
l'acier c'est compliqué parce que déjà
c'est une une production par nature
carbonée. Alors on peut décarboner
l'acier va sous-entendre de décarboner
la production d'électricité
décarboner enfin production
d'électricité pour faire tourner les
fours et après de de réfléchir au à
l'acier que je mets enfin le ce que je
transforme en acier. Est-ce que c'est de
la ferraille ou est-ce que c'est du
mineret de fer ? Euh si c'est de la
ferraille, je suis dans une démarche
plutôt d'économie circulaire, de
recyclage. Donc il y a il y a ça. Mais
je pense par exemple si je prends une
usine qui fait des shampoings,
mon usine qui fait des shampoings, elle
peut être à zé à zéro émission carbone
ou faible émission carbone. Mais si mes
composants matière première viennent de
l'autre bout du monde, donc déjà avec un
impact transport énorme, euh je vais pas
être en en en bonne en bonne situation.
Si euh les matières premières sont
extraites de manière désastreuse ou à
l'autre bout du monde dans des usines
qui ne respectent pas les mêmes normes
environnementales et sociales, ça va pas
être ça ça va pas non plus être la
panassée. Et si derrière j'ai un
transport ultra carboné que j'ai pas
prévu le moyen de recycler mes
emballages et cetera, alors je peut-être
décarboner mon usine dans l'absolu, mais
j'ai pas résolu le problème. Et et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut lier les politiques
environnementales aux politiques
industrielles. Parce qu'il y a un
message aussi à passer, c'est que
j'ai un copain qui me dit toujours
l'industrie c'est 20 % des émissions,
c'est 100 % des solutions. Alors je sais
pas si je suis totalement d'accord avec
lui. En tout cas une chose est sûre
c'est que si on veut garder notre
confort de vie actuel, on a besoin des
industriels, on a besoin des procédés
industriels pour réaliser ces défis. ce
qu'il faut pas dire qu'il faut être
naïf, ce qu'il faut pas dire qu'il faut
tout accepter, mais on ne sortira pas
euh de de cette situation climatique
sans l'industrie. Maintenant, il faut
avoir une stratégie qui soit liée et
cohérente avec nos ambitions
environnementales. L'autre chose, c'est
qu'il faut à mon avis faire un effort de
planification. Alors la planification
dans l'inconscient français, elle
renvoie beaucoup à je trouve à l'ergolo
pomompiolienne et je pense qu'on est
dans un cadre qui est un peu différent à
la fois le cadre mondialisé, à le cadre
européen qui a évolué euh et la crise
environnementale qui n'était pas là dans
les années 50 et qu'on doit intégrer
dans cet effort de planification.
Et quand on dit la France 2030, France
2030, le discours d'Emmanuel Macron,
j'invite d'ailleurs vous les personnes
qui nous écoutent
à aller faire un tour sur le site de
l'Élysée. Moi, j'ai quand j'ai entendu
le discours d'Emmanuel Macron, j'ai
voulu rentrer dans la mécanique de ce
discours, comprendre ce qu'il y avait
derrière, quand on dit devenir un leader
mondial de l'hydrogène, prendre notre
place dans la conquête spatiale et
cetera. Je m'attendais à des dossiers de
presse, à des choses plus développées et
euh bah quand on va sur le site de
l'Élysée, on nous renvoie vers des
passages Twitter du président de la
République. Ce qui moi m'inquiète sur la
réalité de cette stratégie. Mais ce
qu'il faut, c'est quand on se dit 2030,
c'est quoi ? C'est quoi les moyens qu'on
met sur la table ? Qui sont les acteurs
qui sont dessus ? Quels sont les
indicateurs qu'on suit sur la politique
environnementale ? Moi je pense que le
premier ministre tous les 6 mois, il
devrait rendre compte devant les
citoyens des grands indicateurs de notre
évolution sur les sujets carbone
et il prit le faire sur la politique
industrielle aussi parce que là on va
s'obliger à cadencer et à suivre 2030
c'est très près c'est très loin
et et et ça cette vision long terme on
l'a pas encore. Et vous voyez à une ère
où tout le monde fait venir des cabinets
de conseil, je crois qu'il y a jamais eu
autant de cabinets de conseil dans les
ministères. Et ben je vous dire les Min,
les BCG et bien d'autres euh ils sont
capables je pense de faire de super
tableaux d'indicateurs, des magnifiques
tableaux de bord qui seraient bien
utiles pour piloter ces stratégies et
qu'on en rende compte aux citoyens et
qu'on en rende compte pas tous les 5
ans, qu'on en rende compte devant les
représentants de la nation et qu'on en
rende compte aussi dans les allocutions
publiques. faire savoir d'où on part et
où on veut aller et comment on y va et
comment on avance
en terme en terme de charge fiscale, en
terme de d'avantage fiscal, en terme de
subvention, est-ce que tout se passe
bien ? Est-ce qu'on a on a quand même
une stratégie fiscale ? Est-ce que nos
subventions pour ber
sont sont bien là ? Est-ce que est-ce
que est-ce que c'est bien opéré ? Je
sais pas si ma question est très claire.
Ouais, je la comprends. Euh vous parlez
à la fois de la fiscalité et à la fois
des des aides. Je pense qu'il faut faire
tabou la rasa de tout ça et euh refaire
un En fait Pourquoi je pourquoi je dis
ça ?
On on entend beaucoup parler
dans le débat public
de la fiscalité trop importante en
France, des charges et des cotisations
trop lourdes, de la taxation. Alors ça
c'est pas total, il y a des choses qui
sont pas totalement fausses hein. On a
des écarts par rapport à à nos pères
européens. Il y a peut-être des choses à
faire et on est le roi de la la de la la
petite taxe. Ça dès qu' dès qu'il y a un
problème, on invente une nouvelle taxe
et avec une une espèce de de de
croissance normative dans tous les sens
qui qui sont qui est absolument
insupportable. Je revienne après sur le
principe de précaution parce que tient à
cœur mais euh mais il faut pas se leurer
hein. C'est pas parce qu'on aurait une
fiscalité beaucoup plus faible queon
serait meilleur en terme de de
d'industrie
parce que il y a beaucoup d'industriels
aussi qui font tourner des usines en
France, qui sont restés en France depuis
les débuts de la désindustrialisation
malgré tout le mal qu'on dit et qui sont
là et qui en font une fierté d'être dans
leur territoire et de contribuer à faire
vivre à enfin qui sont heureux de
contribuer à l'effort collectif à
l'économie française qui ont le
sentiment de jouer un rôle euh un rôle
clé et et donc il y a des gens qui
réussissent malgré tout l'enfer qu'on
décrit. Donc il faut aussi se dire
c'est bien particulier
c'est soit ceux qui sont très très fiers
de produire français parce que à
l'export on a encore ce vernis de made
in France. Non, je je je suis pas je
suis à l'export, on est on est un des
pays les plus mauvais exportateurs. On a
dire, on parle beaucoup de nos grands
groupes. Les Italiens, c'est
principalement des ETI spécialisés sur
des marchés des ETI, pardon, des PME
spécialisés sur les marchés de niche et
qui exportent. Les Allemands arrivent
aussi à exporter. Le made in France a
une valeur mais la Dutch qualitat, elle
a aussi une valeur. Le made in Italie,
il a une valeur. Donc non, on a des gens
qui sont vraiment leaders dans leur
secteur parce qu'ils ont su innover.
parce qu'ils ont investi dans les
compétences, parce qu'ils ont investi
dans l'outil productif. On a un triple
sous-investissement en France,
sous-investissement dans les
compétences, on a un outil productif
plus vieillissant et parfois c'est des
choses très bêtes. Je peux vous donner
un exemple d'une entreprise avec
laquelle j'avais travaillé. Euh
à un moment le l'entreprise a fini par
perdre un de ses clients majeurs qui
était Zemens, 10 % du chiffre
d'affaires. Il a dit en fait Zemens m'a
pas prévenu et cetera. Il fallait non en
fait Yen avait fait trois rapports où il
émettait des signaux faibles en disant
attention la qualité de vos machines ne
enfin la la production de vos machine ne
permet plus de satisfaire mes standards
produits eten ça finit par arrêter et là
l'entreprise rentre en crise donc la
plus personne plus personne veut mettre
d'argent en pot ni les actionnaires ni
le la la ni les banques donc c'est la la
banque route assurée mais ça c'était une
erreur stratégique d'entreprise. Cette
entreprise aurait pu continuer si elle
avait fait l'investissement au bon
moment avec son client lui donner des
signaux des signaux des sougnaux faibles
qu'on a un outil productif qui est
vieillissant qui ne peut plus forcément
s'adapter à la demande sans parler des
erreurs d'investissement qui ont pu être
faites et ensuite on a sous-investi dans
l'innovation et ce qu'il faut dire
là-dessus c'est qu'on a quand même eu
des politiques d'état qui ont pris
premier première évolution sur les
cotisations
sociales salarial c'est baladure 93
depuis 93 on narrête pas de faire des
allègements de charge et cetera et ça
n'a pas enrayelé le phénomène de
désindustrialisation tout comme nos
politiques d'innovation n'ont pas permis
d'atteindre les 3 % de la stratégie de
l'isbonne et font qu'on est à à de deux.
Donc on a on a fait des choses qui n'ont
pas marché. Donc ça prouve quand même
qu'on a besoin maintenant de remettre à
plat complètement le système parce que
on corrige à la marge, ça ne fonctionne
pas. On a plein d'aides qui sont euh
allouées dans tous les sens qui relèvent
plutôt du du sous-poudrage. Et bien
remettons les choses à plat, remettons
le système d'aide à plat et faisons
quelque chose qui nous permet de
répondre à ces défis. Et je dis pas
aujourd'hui, j'ai pas j'ai pas écrit de
la réforme fiscale, donc je peux pas
vous dire si les gens payeront plus ou
payeront moins. Par contre, je peux vous
dire une chose, c'est que il faut mettre
tout le monde autour de la table.
peut-être prendre 5 ans pour le faire,
mais retourner aussi retrouver un truc
qui est clé, c'est on est en train de
perdre le principe de consentement à
l'impôt et on est en train de perdre un
principe clé, c'est la solidarité. Plus
personne veut payer d'impôts, pas les
entreprises, les les les on retrouve le
même synomène chez les citoyens. Alors,
il y a ceux qui ont les moyens de faire
ses sessions par des mécanismes de
contournement de l'impôt et cetera, mais
il faut renouer avec un principe de
solidarité autour de l'imposition.
Et ça et ben moi je vois beaucoup de
gens qui me parlent d'allègement de de
charge qui me disent faut encore
abaisser les impôts de production mais
un si on a pas le bon positionnement de
gamme des entreprises si le modèle
économique est pas bon vous pouvez
abaisser les charges autant que vous
voulez on va pas on a aussi un modèle
social à financer on va pas ça ne
fonctionnera pas et de il faut renouer
avec ce principe de consentement à
l'impôt donc il faut tout remettre à
plat et se donner une fiscalité qui va
nous permettre de financer la transition
écologique même pas je sais même plus
s'il faut parler de transition écologiqu
Je crois qu'il faut peut-être parler de
rupture écologique, je sais pas, mais ça
va coûter c'est pas c'est pas 30
milliards, hein. C'est pas 30 milliards
en terme d'infrastructure
et de tout. On est sur des dizaines et
des dizaines de milliards et et ça on
voilà, on rêve, on rêve un peu encore.
Si on fait ça fait ça fait 39 minutes
qu'on fait un constat,
si on fait pas ça, on s'expose à quoi ?
On s'expose à quoi ? À devenir une
station balnére géante,
un pays de tourisme.
On est déjà un pays de tourisme.
On est déjà un pays de tourisme. C'est
vachement bien. Il faut continuer. Je je
dis pas ça. Ça ça ça fait les beaux
jours de certains
certaines entreprises américaines qui
louent des biens dans Paris et qui
contribuent à faire augmenter le prix
des loyers. Euh mais euh non, si on fait
pas ça, qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que un
euh on risque mais ça c'est
collectivement hein, c'est le monde
entier, on risque de ne pas réussir le
paris euh de de limiter le réchauffement
de la planète à 1°gr 5 avec des
conséquences euh qui vont être des euh
mouvements migratoires qui vont être à
la fois des des conséquences
d'infrastructure he parce que nos
infrastructures elles ont pas été
pensées pour supporter un réchauffement
climatique supérieur. C'est la première
chose. Et deuxièmement, ça va être des
conséquences sur sur des mouvements de
population à 1 heure où où on a je sais
pas combien de pourcent de la population
française qui sont prêtes à voter et
européennes he qui sont prêtes à voter
pour des personnes dont le discours
principal est de critiquer l'immigration
mais ils se rendent ils ne se rendent
ils ne se rendent pas compte de ce qui
va se passer et puis on va même avoir
des migrations
intérieures hein dans dans le dans le
pays. Donc on a ce premier défi qu'on
doit qui est une réponse à l'échelle
mondiale et c'est pas c'est pas qu'un
pays qui peut le faire mais nous en tant
qu'européen vu qu'on a on veut toujours
montrer qu'on a un modèle différent, on
peut aussi reprendre une position de
leader là-dessus. C'est-à-dire, on a nos
valeurs euh les valeurs humanistes qu'on
veut prener et cetera, mais on peut
aussi être la trè voie environnementale,
même si la Chine a aussi cette ambition
et on voit qu'ils sont assez agressifs
là-dessus et qu'ils se tiennent pour le
coup à leur à leurs à leurs objectifs.
Donc il y a ça, il y a la deuxième
deuxème chose, c'est bon, le tourisme,
c'est bien mais on a vu que ça créait
pas forcément suffisamment de valeur et
suffisamment d'emploi pour financer
notre modèle social. Donc si on ne
recrée pas d'industrie sur le
territoire, comment on va créer de la
valeur ? va sauvegarder notre modèle
social.
Comment on va sauvegarder notre modèle
social ? Et on a vu que le le choix de
de d'être une une économie de service
était pas forcément une réussite. Et
c'est ça les les deux grands sujets.
Alors après, il y a les questions de
souveraineté, on sera on ne sera parce
que dans les pour moi la la
réindustrialisation, il y a trois
piliers. Il y a le pays de la la
cohésion sociale territoriale,
c'est-à-dire
c'est ce que je vous disais hein, créer
un emploi direct dans l'industrie. On
crée trois à quatre emplois indirects et
donc on va recréer de de l'emploi dans
des dans des zones
ville petite et moyenne. Donc cohésion
sociale et territoriale. Le deuxième
enjeu, c'est l'enjeu de souveraineté,
c'est-à-dire passer d'une situation de
dépendance subie à une situation de
dépendance choisie. Et là, je pense
qu'il y a un vrai rapport de force à
faire à l'échelle européenne parce que
je pense qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de
questions qui vont jouer à l'échelle du
continent. Euh et qu'à un moment, il va
falloir aussi dire à l'Union européenne
ce qu'on fait les enfants sages, hein,
je pense qu'il y a plein de gens qui
contournent un certain nombre de choses
avec les règles européennes. Je veux
dire, vous acceptez la Pologne et la
Hongrie,
la Pologne et la Hongrie qui ne respecte
pas l'état de droit, qui bfou à longueur
de journée les principes européens et on
va faire un qu nerveux parce qu'on va
pas respecter certaines règles sur
l'attribution de marché public. moment,
il aussi falloir remettre les choses à
leur place. On peut être exemplaire,
mais il faut aussi dire que c'est le le
ça participe de de l'avenir aussi du du
continent. Donc donc sur la la
souveraineté, il y a il y a une une
politique à voir pour sortir de de ces
sujets de dépendance. Il va falloir
identifier ce sur quoi on veut vraiment
être indépendant, ce qui est clé. Et moi
ce que je dis, c'est que un, j'ai du mal
à croire aux filières parce que les
filières aujourd'hui en France, on en a
19. général de Gaulle, il était beaucoup
plus concentré sur quelques sujets. Il
s'est dit "Moi, je vais être indépendant
vis-à-vis des Américains." Et c'est
important de dire vis-à-vis des
Américains parce que c'était pas
vis-à-vis d'autres gens. Je vais être
indépendant sur le domaine énergétique,
le nucléaire, je vais être indépendant
dans l'aéronautique, je vais être
indépendant dans le ferroviaire et il y
avait le l'informatique avec le plan
calcul qui a qui a qui a été qui n'a pas
été une réussite. Et il y avait quelque
chose de très clair. Nous, on a 18
filières, 18 filières qui manquent de
cohérence. Vous avez les filières
produits aéronautique automobile, vous
avez les filières grand domaine santé et
cetera. Vous avez la filière par matière
première, bois métallurgie. Et quand
vous êtes une entreprise de la
métallurgie, vous êtes où ? Vous êtes
dans la métallurgie, vous êtes dans
l'aéronautique ou dans l'automobile,
vous êtes partout. Donc ce qui me prouve
bien que il y a quand même une
incohérence là-dedans. Je dis pas qu'il
faut pas de filière, mais il faut
sûrement les repenser autrement.
Peut-être réfléchir en terme de grands
problèmes de société, peut-être les
réunir en terme de dire la filière
mobilité. Et comment est-ce qu'à
l'intérieur de ces filières et ben
certains sous-traitants qui étaient
dépendant de l'automobile et ben je peux
peut-être repositionner certaines
activités vers d'autres modes mobilité
puisqueon a le vélo, on fait de
l'assemblage, on l'ambition ça serait
quand même de faire les pièces qu'on met
qu'on assemble. Euh peut-être qu'on a
certaines activités, notamment des
fondries qu'on pourrait repositionner
sur euh du du des vélos, euh
de cuisine, plein d'autres choses. Je je
fais pas une fixette sur les fonderies,
mais ça me tient un petit peu à cœur
parce qu'on on a tendance un peu les à
les à les oublier.
Euh et il faut raisonner après euh sur
la chaîne de valeur, se dire que on a
des points de force en France et en
Europe. Je prends le semi-conducteur, on
a des entreprises qui sont leaders dans
des aspects de la chaîne de valeur du
semi-onducteur et c'est repartir de ces
points de force dans tous les domaines
pour remonter en amont et en aval la
chaîne de valeur et reconquérir des
positions dominantes. Et c'est donc si
on part dans nos points de force, c'est
partir de nos avantages, mais euh on va
avoir du mal à créer exniilo des choses
que d'autres, sauf ce qu'on juge
vraiment stratégique pour des questions
de défense et cetera et au quelqu'un on
a intérêt à rapatrier vraiment sur le le
territoire euh s'ils ont dans le domaine
de la la santé, de la pharmacie. Et là
il y a il y a des vrais dat
de la data du numérique. Alors le
numérique c'est pas mon sujet mais je
crois que Taric Crim est déjà venu donc
je vous conseille de faire venir et je
vous conseille aussi une pour les gens
qui écoutent d'aller voir les travaux du
quelqu'un de génial qui s'appelle
Ophélie Quelo. Alors je prononce
peut-être pas très très bien son nom
mais qui a travaillé sur aussi tout ce
qui est infrastructure dans le numérique
notamment les câbles et cetera parce que
le numérique tout le monde se dit ah
c'est un truc évanaissant. Enfin, le
numérique c'est surtout du hard avec des
bons procédés industriels, donc des
câbles euh des infrastr enfin des câbles
infrastructure physique, tous nos
support de communication et cetera. Et
après, il y a la cou couche soft à
laquelle tout le monde pense et sur
lequel on est on n'est pas plus
souverain que qu'ailleurs, mais c'est
tout tous ces sujets à à envisager. Euh
vous parliez de points de force
en terme de guerre économique, c'est
important les points de force. Qu'est-ce
qui nous reste à l'heure actuelle ?
Ah, qu'est-ce qui nous reste ? On a on a
perdu un on a on a dilapidé un certain
nombre de choses. Je
où on s'est fait, permettez-moi
l'expression,
mettre en laisse.
Euh oui. Alors oui, on s'est fait en
fait je pense qu'on a on a parfois
on n pas voulu voir en fait le problème
c'est qu'on a pas de en se
désindustrialisant, on a perdu aussi la
une réflexion stratégique. C'estàd que
aujourd'hui dans un certain nombre un
certain nombre de personnes dans la
haute administration de responsable
politique ou ou autres ont on ont perdu
le réflexe de ce qui était un actif
stratégique. Quand on fait on vend
Alstom à ADJ
alors que on fait du nucléaire nos nos
atout, on se dit pas un moment mais on
est en train de d'obérer sur le temps
long notre notre souveraineté. Et là, on
est on est sur un un vrai acte de
prédation et finalement personne alors
personne s'en est ému. Et en même temps,
je pense qu'il y a un vrai trauma parce
que on a eu un affaire sensible il y a
pas longtemps. Il y a un un film qui va
sortir sur le combat des salariés
d'Alstom sur France 3 la semaine
prochaine aussi. Donc il y a il y a
quelque chose qui reste, c'est
qu'onarrive pas à le digérer et pourtant
à l'instant euh on s'est pas dit que ça
allait euh obérer notre souveraineté. Et
en même temps, on a des points de force
sur des entreprises qui sont pas connues
Photon Nice qui a été racheté
inextrémiste parce qu'il y a eu aussi
une réaction des médias et de l'opinion
publque. On a quand même un certain
nombre de sous-traitants d'Airbus qui
savent faire des choses. On a on on a on
a des ST microélectroniques. Tout ce qui
se passe à Croll dans l'électronique, on
a des gens qui sont capables de penser
dans ce pays. Donc on n'est pas
complètement à poil. On a quand même une
culture industrielle. On a on a tout ça.
Mais euh ça il faut mettre du lion
autour. C'est pas parce que vous avez
des gens dans leur coin qui savent faire
des choses que ça on fait une stratégie
industrielle et que ça nous prémunit des
prédations. Si on préserve pas en plus
ce qu'on a, si dans nos stratégies de
commande publique, les stratégies de
commande publique, on est capable
d'aller se maquer avec des entreprises
américaines alors qu'on a des solutions
françaises ou européennes ou
européennes.
C'est c'est c'estd qu' on prend un
pistolet, on met ses deux pieds comme ça
et on se tire deux balles et après on se
dit ou on n'est pas content. Je je je
vais pas m'énerver plus. C'est pas bon
pour mon mon cœur.
Une petite question. Comment on
réindustrialise la France dans un
contexte de pénurie d'énergie et
d'énergie chère alors que certaines
usines s'arrêtent déjà parce que le
budget énergie est devenu insupportable.
Je pense justement par exemple aux
fonderies et aux autres industries
lourdes gros consommateur.
Question du petit Pascal. Alors petit
Pascal, je le remercie pour sa question
ardue mais c'est un des sujets la
transition écologique, c'est que
aujourd'hui on a on a on a un certain
nombre alors l'énergie
chère, on n'est pas forcément un des
pays avec l'énergie la plus chère. On
est un des pays avec l'énergie la plus
décarbonée et on n'est pas forcément le
pays avec l'énergie la plus chère. Et
notamment euh on avait un avantage
compétitif pour nos industries sur le
sujet de de l'énergie. Euh mais ça va
devenir un sujet, je l'entends mais il y
a il y a une une réflexion à avoir de
comment dire plus on va développer aussi
certaines énergies énergies
renouvelables, plus on va réfléchir sur
l'hydrogène, plus on va abaisser les
coûts de les coûts de de de de
production. Euh mais euh ça va prendre
du temps et à l'instanté une construire
un parc. Il y a de très bons
spécialistes de l'énergie, de la
question énergétique. Donc je vais pas
non plus trop répondre et je je pense
que je conseillerai au petit Pascal
aussi d'aller voir ce qui se fait
notamment les dernières études qui ont
été faites. Mais euh il faut aussi avoir
des réflexions sur un alors on a le
sujet de l'acceptabilité qui revient
toujours sur les usines mais qu'on va
avoir aussi parce que si on veut
produire assez d'énergie pour tout ce
qu'on a besoin, on va devoir réimplanter
des parcs et auolien photovoltaïque et
ce qui vont faire
et des productions de terre rar
et des productions de terre rare. Mais
alors tout ça l'enjeu derrière c'est
l'enjeu des filières de recyclage qu'on
a qu' dont j'ai pas du tout dont j'ai
pas du tout parlé qui sont aussi un des
alors plusieurs choses. Il y a un enjeu
d'écoconception dans certains domaines
et il y a un enjeu de gestion des
déchets. C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
acheter des matières premières reste
moins cher qu'acheter des matières
recyclées quand on sait les recycler. Et
il y a un certain nombre de choses qu'on
ne recycle plus aujourd'hui dans les
quand vous avez des déchets. Vous savez
pas encore faire vous les brûlez, vous
les envoyez chez chez chez les tiers
chez les des pays étrangers. Donc il
faut un réduire les déchets, réemployer
les déchets en les recyclant et réduire
voir viser le zéro déchet parce que le
polluer moins c'est toujours polluer
hein. Donc c'est viser le zéro déchet
par du réemploi, par du recyclage et ça
nous oblige à repenser dans beaucoup de
cas et je pense pas forcément au
photovoltaïque he mais je peux par
exemple penser aux fringues, aux
bouteilles, aux ordinateurs, ça va nous
obliger à repenser le produit de manière
à le rendre recyclable parce que vous
avez beaucoup de choses qui sont
aujourd'hui pensées sans les solutions
de recyclage
parce que c'est trop cher, parce que on
jusque-là on avait pas d'intérêt
là-dessus. Euh et donc
c'est c'est pour ça qu'il y a aussi tout
un monde à réinventer autour de la
réindustrialisation. Euh c'est euh
repenser ces modes de de nos modes de
consommation à nous, mais c'est repenser
nos modes de distribution, mais c'est
aussi repenser les modes de conception
et de production. Et et il y a encore
aujourd'hui trop de produits qui sont
pensés euh à la fois qui sont pas
écoonçus puis qui réfléchissent pas sur
l'usage des matières et puis sur la
pénurie des terra pour venir là-dessus.
Je crois qu'il va aussi faire
pas de pénurie de terrar. euh pas de
pénurie de tarard mais sur les enfin les
tensions à venir surtout voilà les
tensions à à venir euh sur les matières
ce qu'on appelle les matières premières
critiques. D'ailleurs, quand on regarde
les stratégies européennes 2017, on
évoque un certain nombre de composants
sur lesquels on est en situation de
dépendance. 2021, le même rapport, on
accroit notre situation de dépendance.
la stratégie européenne accroit notre
situation de dépendance sur les les
terres les terres rares, enfin les
matières premières critiques parce que
les terres rares sont pas forcément des
terres rares d'ailleurs euh voir pas du
tout rares. Donc on accroit notre
dépendance en matière première critique,
on accroit
le tassement de notre balance
commerciale, enfin le le le le le fossé
de la balance commerciale puisque pour
atteindre nos objectifs
environnementaux, on va devoir faire
venir des éoliennes leaders chinois, des
panneaux photovoltaïques leaders chinois
parce qu'on a pas su structurer les
filières en Europe et donc ça va aussi
plaider un moment pour sûrement aller
mettre des barrières tarifa et des
contraintes ce que sont en train de
faire les Américains sur le sujet des
composants électroniques en disant il
faut des usines et Après, on mettra des
taxes très fortes pour ceux qui n'est
pas fait en Europe. On devrait avoir ces
ces ces logiques en Europe parce qu'on a
la capacité de le faire.
Et on doit aussi avoir des réflexions
sur les ces approvisionnements. Euh
un euh la Chine aujourd'hui est en forte
maîtrise sur l'extraction et le
raffinage des matières premières
critiques.
On a peu d'entreprises européennes qui
se positionnent dessus, mais il y a
peut-être l'enjeu de recréer des
entreprises européennes qui sont
capables d'aller
prendre des marchés ou
ce qu'on a pas fait parce qu'on les a on
a laissé la Chine prendre la place.
réfléchir à comment aider les États
africains à devenir autonomes dans
l'extraction et le raffinage des
matières premières africains en Amérique
du Sud qui font leur richesse et donc
c'est aussi leur redonner les moyens de
leur développement et donc nous on on se
donne aussi les moyens d'avoir des
différentes possibilités
d'approvisionnement. Troisième chose
c'est réfléchir peut-être à refaire des
mines en Europe.
Est-ce que les gens vont l'accepter
? Les gens déjà sont pas prêts à
accepter usines. Quand on dit des usines
qui font des vestes, ça posera pas de
problème. Si je donne des usines
chimiques déjà vous allez avoir vous
allez avoir de de de la réaction. Et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a un rôle du
consommateur et du citoyen du citoyen
acteur.
Je sais que ça ça plaît pas hein quand
on dit ce genre de chos mais mais
qu'est-ce pour avoir notre indépendance
pour tenir nos nos nos notre paris de la
transition, il va falloir aussi qu'on
accepte des choses parce qu'aujourd'hui
la chose qu'on a accepté c'est de nous
dresponsabiliser délocaliser notre
responsabilité environnementale
et notre pollution
et notre pollution. Donc ces questions,
il faut les poser et il faut savoir
qu'une mine en Europe, elle aura
toujours des standards environnementaux
et sociaux. beaucoup plus élevé
qu'ailleurs et que c'est pas parce qu'on
le voit pas, c'est pas parce que c'est
pas devant nous que ça n'existe pas.
C'est c'est ça m'a l'air très ça m'a je
vais prendre ça tout de suite après. Ça
ça m'a l'air très compliqué. Par
exemple, je vous donne le chèque le
chèque énergie de notre premier
ministre.
On a 38 millions de français qui vont
toucher 100 € parce que il touchent
moins de 2000 € net par mois, ce qui est
déjà beaucoup. Hm hm.
Euh comment on va pouvoir faire
comprendre aux gens qui ont déjà du mal
à terminer le mois s'ils n'achètent pas
des choses rapidement consommables et
pas très cher de Chine ? Comment on va
leur faire comprendre ? Comment on va
leur faire accepter de serrer la
ceinture à fond pour la terre, le
business, la France ? Comment on va
faire ça ? Est-ce que en terme de
communication de rêve, vous connaissez
le le poème qui termine par "Je sortirai
de ce monde où l'action n'est pas sœur
du rêve". Le renoncement de
Saint-Pierre, le reniement de
Saint-Pierre.
Est-ce qu'il manque pas un peu de rêve ?
Est-ce qu'il manque pas un peu de cap ?
Est-ce qu'il manque pas un petit peu pas
un homme providentiel mais quelqu'un qui
nous dit "OK, maintenant il faut y
aller, il faut se redresser les manches,
pas un discours wishful thinking, nous
sommes en guerre là là."
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. Je Alors, sur
l'échèque énergie déjà, il me semble on
donne 100 € pour acheter pour pour
acheter l'énergie qui est extrêmement
taxé. Donc, quel est l'effort réel pour
l'État ?
Pas beaucoup. Donc donc bon la deuxième
chose c'est qu'on sait que ces
transitions elles m'ont posé des
questions sur le pouvoir d'achat.
Je crois qu'on peut faire des politiques
de soutien à la demande ciblée.
Vous avez fait du les politiques de
soutien à la demande pour l'automobile ?
Les chèqus à la enfin les primes à la
cage, c'est ça ? euh il y a eu un
certain nombre de choses, sauf que euh
en l'occurrence
euh cette politique de la demande, elle
a rarement profité directement à
l'économie française puisque euh si on
achète des voitures qui sont assemblées
à l'autre bout du monde avec des
écosystèmes que en plus l'automobile est
quand même l'endroit où vous avez
l'organisation la plus les écosystèmes
les plus les plus resserrés, c'estàd les
les le c'est tous les phénomènes du LINE
avec l'approvisionnement presque en
temps direct des usines et cetera, pas
de stock, stock porté par sous-traitant
et cetera.
Euh donc cette politique de la demande
qui existé, qui peut soutenir euh nos
nos nos concitoyens les plus fragiles
dans cette transition, elle ne profite
pas à l'industrie française. Donc on
peut faire des choses euh qui profitent
à la à l'industrie française et qui et
qui vont profiter à ceux qui vont être
pénalisés par cette transition. Mais
manière, on va on parle de d'isoler euh
euh les euh l'isolation thermique des
bâtiments. Tout le monde parle de mettre
des pompes à chaleur et cetera. Et bien
les pompes à chaleur faisont des pompes
à chaleur produites en France. Et comme
ça, si on met une politique de la
demande euh 1, on va créer de l'emploi,
de l'emploi peut-être plus qualifié.
Donc euh on on va recréer une dynamique
positive. de euh on va on on va quand on
va faire une politique de la la demande,
elle va directement irriguer notre
économie plutôt qu'elle irriguer les
l'économie euh des autres. Donc il y a
ça et je pense qu'il y a aussi un
principe à la fois de lucidité, de
solidarité.
Moi j'estime que euh je travaille dans
le conseil donc je je suis pas à
plaindre. Donc j'estime que c'est mon
devoir de soutenir l'écosystème
productif à l'auteur de mes moyens.
Vous n'êtes pas sécessionniste.
Je ne suis pas sécessionniste.
Exactement. Et donc je et et par
ailleurs à partir du moment aussi on va
rééquilibrer les choses euh dans la
mondialisation, on va aussi arrêter
d'être les naïfs, c'est-à-dire se dire
on en a qui ferment leurs frontières
pour certaines choses pour développer
leur leurs entreprises d'exation. Mais
la même chose euh l'exemple de
l'agriculture quand on avait une balance
commerciale plutôt positive pendant très
longtemps qui est en train de se
dégrader. On a dans nos concurrents
directs
européens et aussi concurrents plus loin
des gens qui ne sont pas confrontés aux
mêmes standards environnementaux que
nous. Donc on a un déficit de
productivité de compétitivité qui se
fait sur les normes qu'on se fixe qui
sont meilleures pour le consommateur. Et
bien pourquoi on ne récompense pas ceux
qui qui produisent en France et qui
respectent ça ? Pourquoi on accepte du
coup qu'il soit concurrencé par des gens
qui ont des standards moins élevés ?
Ça alors je réponds pas totalement à la
question et sur la question du parce que
je sais que c'est un vrai dilemme et que
j'ai pas non plus, je le dis de manière
très honnête, j'ai pas forcément les
réponses à toutes les questions sur le
pouvoir d'achat et que ça va être un un
vrai un vrai un vrai sujet qu' a il y a
des mécanismes à à faire et si quelqu'un
a la réponse absolue, je pense que c'est
un menteur. La deuxième chose sur le
rêve et l'imaginaire,
on a une société qui ne rêve plus.
On n plus de grands rêve collectif et il
y a il y a plusieurs choses à dire
dessus. Je vais peut-être faire ici mon
passage sur principe de précaution qui
pour moi est le symbole d'une société
qui se meurt.
Principe de précaution a été
constitutionnalisé. C'est bien de mettre
des des normes élevées et cetera, mais
on est tellement allé loin qu'on a peur
de tout. On met des normes pour tout qui
sont hyper contraignantes, qui ont à la
fois des avantages et en même temps euh
et en même temps pour certaines sont
ineptes et plus personne a envie de
prendre le risque quand vous êtes sur
l'implantation d'une usine finalement
c'est un peu à qui prendra la
responsabilité si ça cafouille et donc
mettra son tampon sur l'autorisation
administrative. On met des principes de
précaution partout et on est en train
donc crever
littéralement. Et donc on n' plus de
grands rêves collectifs, on a plus de
narratifs collectifs. Le seul narratif
qu'on nous propose aujourd'hui, les
seuls qui proposent un narratif, c'est
les parties d'extrême droite. Les
parties d'extrême droite qui a un
narratif fermé, qui a un narratif sur la
myification d'avant et qui n'est pas
quelque chose qui se projette, qui exclu
les autres, mais qui a un discours qui
rentre en résonance avec l'expérience
quotidienne d'un certain nombre de
Français. Et beaucoup des discours qu'on
entend aujourd'hui sont complètement
déconnectés des réalités, sans parler du
fait que les gens qui les tiennent ont
pu être au pouvoir à un moment. Donc
moi, je pense que légitimement les gens
se disent "Arrêtez de nous prendre pour
des gens bons aussi la situation, vous
en êtes responsable."
Et euh je peux pas vous dire je peux pas
vous dessiner quel devrait être le grand
récit national. j'estime que j'ai pas
forcément la légitimité a en tout cas
parce que moi je travaille beaucoup sur
l'industrie et je connais pas assez bien
peut-être les autres sujets. Voyez même
déjà l'industrie c'est tellement large
qu'on peut pas être expert de tout et
qu'il faut toujours aborder les choses
avec beaucoup d'humilité. Mais euh
quand j'ai écrit ma thèse la première
préconisation que j'ai donné, j'ai dit
et d'ailleurs c'est celle dont je me
souviens le mieux. Si vous me demandiez
de de me dire c'est quoi les 35000
préconisations recommandations que tu as
mis dans ta thèse, je me souviens d'une
seule qui était la première. C'était
reconstruire un imaginaire autour de
l'industrie
euh parce que l'industrie, elle a été
euh beaucoup dénigrée dans le débat
public. Et quand je dis imaginaire,
parce qu'il y a eu un un propos euh de
la ministre de l'industrie Anagorinaché
euh dans le casre d'un événement BPI où
elle dit "L'industrie c'est pour ton
pays, c'est pour la magie" qui a été
à la fois je peux pas la blâmer parce
qu'elle a essayé de de créer quelque
chose sur l'industrie et à la fois
c'était extrêmement maladroit parce que
ça occulte toute une toute une réalité
de l'industrie. L'industrie, c'est aussi
les 38, les 48, les 58, le travail
posté, c'est des gens qui travaillent
debout dans le froid. C'est aussi des
conditions difficiles et on ne peut pas
rendre invisible dans le débat public
cette réalité.
Parce que si on veut reconstruire
l'industrie et si on veut recréer un
imaginaire, c'est aussi dire il y a une
part de difficile dans l'industrie. Ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il y a pas de métier
extraordinaire, ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas des choses magiques dans
l'industrie. Les procédés de
transformation de la matière, quand vous
allez dans une usine qui fait de des
barrettes d'aluminium, s'il y a des
choses exceptionnelles quand vous
regardez, il y a plein de choses, mais
il y a aussi une part des métiers
difficiles et vous pouvez avoir des
métiers aussi qualifiés qui vont être
difficiles. Et ce qui est dramatique,
c'est qu'à travers cette ce discours, on
essaie de rendre l'industrie
merveilleuse, l'industrie 4.0. Toutes
les usines seront pas des industries 4.0
parce que ça ne répond pas forcément à
une réalité du marché. Tout ne va pas
être totalement automatisé. Et on a
aussi besoin d'emploi peu ou pas
qualifiés parce que c'est aussi une
réalité. On a aussi des gens qui sont
peu ou pas qualifiés parce que la vie a
fait qu'ils n'ont pas été beaucoup
qualifiés parce qu'ils avaient pas
d'appétence pour les études et cetera et
qu'il y a aussi une réalité. C'est qu'on
est en train, on a massifié
l'enseignement supérieur. C'est génial.
Et en même temps, on n' pas créé autant
de de postes pour des gens pack plus 5
qu'on crée de de de gens diplômés. Ce
qui crée énormément de frustrations dans
la société parce que on a des gens qui
se retrouvent à aspirer à quelque chose
légitimement au regard des diplômes
qu'ils ont et en même temps à ne pas
trouver d'emploi et donc à accepter tout
et n'importe quoi, être maltraité, à
faire c à faire cinq stages. Voyz que
tout le monde a envie de faire cinq
stages où on vous on vous soupe à être
déconsidéré. Et au-delà de ce sujet, je
le dis sûrement malade droitement et et
je je je prie les gens de de m'excuser
les gens qui nous écoutent. L'autre
chose, c'est qu'à travers ce discours
sur l'industrie, on on a toute une
partie de la population qui est rendue
invisible.
Les ouvriers, tous les premiers de corvé
dont on a parlé pendant le confinement
avec le Covid.
Covid, heureusement qu'ils étaient là
d'ailleurs.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? Qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait pour eux ? Est-ce que on
s'est ému du du sort des personnes qui
travaillent au Caes dans les
supermarchés ? qu'on a revalorisé leur
salair ? Est-ce qu'on les considère
mieux ? Mais
non, on a utilisé le le quelques
subventions pour mettre des caisses
automatiques.
Voilà. Et et et à travers cette invisib
cette le fait de masquer une partie de
cette réalité qui est dure mais qui est
là et et c'est comme ça et il y a pas de
honte à l'avoir et il faut pas non plus
j'ai l'impression
en être fier aussi.
Il faut en être fier mais je pense qu'il
faut être fier de de de tout. Enfin,
c'est je pas dire tout le monde a une
place dans sa société. C'est tellement
de tarte à la crème, c'est cucu. Mais on
les invibilise. Et pourquoi on les on
les rend invisibles ? Parce qu'on ne les
représente plus.
C'est quoi la représentation médiatique
et politique des des des gens dont on
parle ?
Les gilets jaunes.
Les gilets jaunes. Les gilets jaunes
mais qu'on a peint des peints d'une
manière assez caricaturale. Dès qu'on a
pu les accuser d'être de bons racistes,
ça a été fait. ou l'autre billet qu'on
l'autre schéma qu'on a festival de cann
on a fait un film sur quelque chose j'en
parlais j'ai promis de je dirai son nom
c'est Aurélien c'est un très bon copain
à moi. Il a une newletter qui s'appelle
Industrie for Good. Si vous voulez vous
intéresser au sujet de l'industrie, il
traite plein de choses et il faut aller
voir ça. Je suis désolée des pages de
pub. On avait dit pas de pub mais bon me
pardonnerez
ou pas
ou pas. Mais non mais parce que c'était
passionnant. On a eu cette discussion
passionnante où il me disait "Mais
regarde quand on sait quand on s'émeux
des classes populaires, c'est à Cann
quand on affie un film misérabiliste et
là toute la bourgeoisie se dit "Oh mon
dieu, c'est terrible, mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait concrètement ? C'est pas pour
autant qu'il y aura plus d'ouvriers ou
de ou de de sal d'employés représentés à
l'Assemblée nationale. C'est pas pour
autant que quand on a un sujet de de de
qui concerne l'industrie, on fait venir
ceux qui font tourner les usines, on
fait déjà pas peu intervenir les patrons
de PME, de TI, mais alors ceux qui font
tourner les usines au quotidien, on ne
les voit jamais. On ne les voit jamais.
Et si on veut recréer l'imaginaire,
c'est aussi faire parler ces gens.
Vous connaissez le le bon leader ? Le
bon leader, c'est celui qui se bat pour
la dignité des faibles.
Question internet, question du petit
Nono.
Il y a beaucoup d'entreprises.
Petit Pascal, le petit Nono.
Oui,
il y a Ah, ça suffit.
Il y a beaucoup d'entreprises qui ne
prennent même pas la peine de trier les
poubelles. Il y a beaucoup de poubelles
vertes et jaunes qui sont bainées dans
le même camion car trop coûteux pour les
entreprises. Comment on fait pour
corriger ça ? Comment on peut dire aux
gens de bien trier quand finalement tout
est incinéré ?
les questions sont sont ardues, bah déjà
on va commencer par arrêter de tout tout
incinérer et et donc là l'enjeu c'est de
créer les filières qui qui vont faire ça
et c'était une aberration hein parce que
c'est en effet bénéf vous faites
conscienusement le tri, vous voyez que
tout finit dans le même camion derrière
il y a éventuellement des opérations de
retrie puis on compacte, on enfouie, on
brûle. Donc là, il y a je pense que le
le sujet c'est pas tant les entreprises
qu'on enfin les les c'est c'est c'est de
de de créer euh des filières où on va
faire quelque chose de ça. C'està-dire
que si on sait que la finalité c'est de
tout bainer, au final le le tri n'a pas
d'importance. Si on structure pas, si on
met pas des obligations, si ce n'est pas
respecté, alors en effet ça sert à rien.
Et il y a il y a il y a il y a l'enjeu à
mon avis, c'est de créer ces filières de
recyclage. Numéro 1.
Question internet de Super Jupa. Que
pensent-elle des crédits impôt
recherchent les entre guillemets CIR CIR
? Je crois que ça a eu des vertus qui ne
sont pas forcément démontrées, que ça
n'a pas forcément profité à l'industrie
parce que on a en fait c'est plutôt des
grandes entre il y a eu il y a eu
plusieurs choses he qui ont été il y a
eu des rapports au Sénat Assemblée
nationale, il y a eu des rapports je
crois d'association association de la
recherche, je sais plus comment elle
s'appelle. pas les mêmes choses qui ont
été faites. Un, ça crée pas forcément
d'emploi dans la recherche,
ça a créé des mécanismes où on dévie le
cire pour faire autre chose. Euh de euh
ça profite pas forcément au TPE PME
parce que c'est compliqué à mobiliser. 3
on a créé toute une ingénierie de
cabinet de conseil autour de ça euh et
qui prélève jusqu'à 10 % sur
l'obstention du CIR. Donc je en fait je
pense que l'idée fondamentalement est
bonne. Maintenant l'efficacité réelle
sur l'économie et euh le développement
dans l'industrie euh on peut la
questionner euh fortement et en fait
c'est le CR comme le CICE hein, Crédit
impôt euh compétitivité entreprise je
crois c'est Ouais c'est ça euh sur les
abaissements de charge. Ça a aucun effet
par exemple dans l'industrie parce que
ça touche dans l'industrie. Les salaires
sont plutôt hauts ça. Donc ça ne
concerne pas les c'est pas les
entreprises qui en bénéfici
entreprises industrielles qui en
bénéficient et voir pire ça contribue à
rechercher une embauche sur des salaires
plus bas pour en bénéficier. Donc c'est
un effet délétaire et en fait quand on
regarde le coût de du dispositif donc et
le nombre d'emplois créés c'est par
c'est pas ou peu ou pas efficace. Je
mets toujours un peu de nuance mais en
tout cas c'est pas des des il a été
prouvé hein, c'est pas c'est pas des
choses qui sortent de ma tête que ces
deux dispositifs euh en terme de
politique industrielle manquait un peu
leur leur leur leur but.
Question. Quels sont pour vous les
secteurs les plus facilement
relocalisables en France dans des délais
raisonnables et où les contraintes sont
les moins fortes ?
Secteur facilement relocalisable. À mon
avis, on peut faire beaucoup de choses
dans le domaine de la de la santé, la
chimie.
Euh, il y a aussi tout un enjeu à
développer les biothèques et les
medtech. Euh biotech qui on encore on
produit encore en France, mais on un peu
on est un peu en retard par rapport à ce
que peut faire l'Allemagne. Euh les
Mtech qui sont en train de se
développer. Euh on peut faire un certain
nombre de choses à mon avis dans le
domaine de l'électronique. Euh on a vu
par exemple, alors je ne serai pas vous
dire exactement, je crois que c'était
des câbles, mais je suis plus sûr, deux
entreprises en Alsace qui se sont
entendu pour coinvestir dans une usine
pour sécuriser leurs approvisionnements.
Et donc ce que ça dit aussi, c'est que
la relocalisation ou la la renaissance
de l'industrie en France, parce qu'il y
a pas que des sujets de relocalisation,
elle va passer par des nouveaux modèles
d'entreprise euh à la fois euh de la
coopération, la coopération sur du
co-investissement, la coopération sur
euh la recherche de marché ensemble,
c'est-à-dire d'arrêter d'être dans la
concurrence toujours frontale, mais
essayer de travailler ensemble pour se
positionner mieux sur la chaîne de
valeur. avancer en meute.
Avancer en meute comme le font très bien
nos amis les Italiens et et et la la
relocalisation. Donc il y a ça, chimie
enfin médicament, chimie, donc je dis
santé, l'électronique où on peut faire
des choses. On on a sûrement des enjeux
dans l'automobile
euh parce que en fait on se rend compte
qu'on a on a beaucoup de choses qui sont
maintenant aujourd'hui notamment
Stellentis. Renault est en train de
faire des rapatrier des choses en
France. Stellantis
par la force des choses.
Par la force des choses et Stellantis
lance maintenant des nouveaux modèles
directement en Asie.
Et ensuite, il va falloir descendre
vraiment à l'échelle dans la chaîne de
valeur enfin j'ai envie de dire
composant par composant ou sous-ensemble
par sous-ensemble pour voir ce qu'on a
en point de force et ce qu'on a des
légitimités à à à à rapatrier. Assez
rapidement. Le semi-conducteur par
exemple, aujourd'hui on en parle
beaucoup. Euh c'est un un vrai débat
entre les marchés qu'on veut servir et
euh les ambitions qu'on peut donner sur
euh la réduction de enfin sur la course
à la miniaturisation. marché cœur reste
quand même des marchés sur plutôt des
semi-conducteurs de taille les plus
importantes et euh et pas forcément les
plus petit. Euh faut savoir que la
relocalisation, il faut qu'elle serve
d'abord nos marchés nationaux européens
avant de d'envisager
de les produire à l'autre bout du monde
enfin de exporter l'aut du monde.
Question bonjour. Comment protéger notre
industrie quand tous nos systèmes sont
potentiellement contaminés par des
puissances étrangères ?
La moindre avancée la moindre avancée
nous est immédiatement ponctionnée car
il y a du Lenovo chez Bull au CEA au
CNRS. Or nous n'avons plus les chaînes
de production suffisantes pour produire
des puces et autres technologies. Nous
en sommes nous n'en sommes-nous pas
réduits à être le ghost writer des
puissances comme la Chine et les USA ?
Alors, ça c'est une question qui est
double parce que c'est à la fois euh nos
notre nos systèmes informatiques, en
tout cas nous le sujet numérique sur
lequel on est en effet euh enfin je
pense qu'on est complètement naïf. On on
se fait encore des choses, on n'arrive
pas à se prémunir.
Attends,
je peux vous couper ? On n'arrive pas à
se prémunir
en fait.
On narrive pas à se prémunir. Ça veut
dire que nos services de renseignement
ont pas de cellules de prospective dans
l'industrie pour protéger nos business,
donc protéger l'emploi, donc protéger le
pays. On n' pas de cellules de
prospective euh suffisamment agressive.
C'est c'est quoi ? Ah il y a il y a
plusieurs choses.
C'est compliqué qu'il y a toujours
tellement de choses qui arrivaient à
tout à répondre à tout. C'est euh
vous imaginez pas ce qu'il y a dans nos
têtes. C'est encore ça.
C'est le bazar parfois dans ma tête. Je
pars d'une idée, j' tiens une autre.
Premièrement, sur les sujets de de de de
d'outils qu'on on utilise euh et sur
lequel on peut avoir des des vols
d'information, ça va être assez
compliqué parce que euh c'était il y a
15 ans qu'il fallait réagir. C'estàd que
aujourd'hui euh
vous avez discuté avec Taric. J'ai alors
c'était c'était avec Ophélie et c'était
il y a 2h mais euh je mais euh mais
Taric aurait pu dire la même chose mais
en tout cas mais mais sur plein d'autres
choses he on a ses retards. C'est euh le
semi-conducteur euh c'est pour moi le
symbole type de la de la mondialisation
parce que on avait des entreprises très
intégrées verticalement et puis
et ça montrait aussi nos faiblesses.
C'estàd que nos faiblesses dans
l'électronique, on les voyait déjà dans
les années 80, on on le savait avant et
et justement Valérie Régie Giscardessin
avait essayé de faire des choses dans le
domaine des semi-conducteurs et n'avait
pas réussi parce que nos marchés cœur
enfin les les notre production en fait
les approvisionnements allaient se faire
directement chez les étrangers et on
arrivait pas à exporter puisque ça se
faisait déjà à proximité des lieux de de
production. OK, il y a eu cet échec euh
on on a une prise de conscience mais qui
est relativement faible. C'estàd que peu
d'entreprises sont sensibilisées au
sujet de cybersécurité mais même de de
parfois de présence d'étudiants
étrangers
dans des laboratoires
qui font des recherches extrêmement
confidentielles et on ne se dit pas
alors c'est qu'il faut pas être méfiant
de tout le monde mais un peu quand même
on ne se dit pas qu'ils peuvent aussi
servir des des puissances étrangères
c'est-à-dire queils peuvent aussi
transférer des données. On a encore trop
d' trop d'entreprises qui vont laisser
traîner des ordinateurs dans des
chambres d'hôtel, des ordinateurs dans
des trains qui comme par hasard se font
se font voler. Donc on se prémunit à la
fois, on est en retard technologique,
donc on n plus les outils, on n pas nos
technologies souveraines là-dessus et à
la fois on n' pas forcément les
principes de précaution nécessaires.
On les avait pourtant
on les avait mais moi je suis qu' qu'on
se voit qu'il y a quand même un certain
nombre de de choses sur lequelles on on
ne fait pas attention. Ensuite, il y a
les choix de technologie que font les
administrations
françaises. quand on prend quand alors
quand on se félicite que tu as laiss ce
Mac et Google sur un sujet de cloud.
Bon, quand on se dit que des entreprises
ou des administrations françaises
utilisent un cloud qui ne soit pas euh
un cloud
souverain, quand on parle d'un cloud
souverain GAI, c'est qu'on fait entrer
des tiers qui qui sont américains avec
toute l'extraterritorialité de droit
américain et cetera. Tout ça ça pose un
certain nombre de questions. Et ensuite
il y a l'inverse, c'est sur les
productions sur lesquelles on s'est mis
en situation de dépendance très forte.
Alors à la fois on sait faire des
choses, il faut faut le dire. Je sais
pas si demande on a un intérêt à faire
du 2 nanomè en France ou du 3 nanom. Je
sais pas si en terme de marché on est
capable de le de le tenir parce que on
ne sait pas faire tout le reste. Donc
est-ce qu'il faut commencer par refaire
tout le reste ? Puis de nanomètre de la
la soudure des puces.
Ouai pardon.
euh dans quel qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui va précéder ? Donc c'est un c'est
des vraies réflexion stratégique à avoir
et à un moment il va falloir aussi se
dire euh prendre le risque d'investir
dans des choses
et de se planter.
Mais là on l'a fait beaucoup là. On a
fait la chasse aux licornes avec notre
gouvernement.
Non mais la chasse au licorne mais on a
fait la chasse sur licorne. Moi je veux
bien mais on a fait x explications de de
start-up qui font des pizzas. C'est
vachement bien. Donc ce qu'on veut c'est
des start-ups qui aillent dans le
domaine industriel, ce qu'on appelle les
start-ups industriels. Et euh il y a
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Éléonor Blondo
qui porte très bien ce message. Elle a
monté tout un collectif, elle essaie de
bouger parce qu'elle elle a développé
une start-up et quand elle a voulu
rentrer dans les phases
d'industrialisation, elle a eu toutes
les mâs du monde à trouver de l'argent.
Et le problème c'est que il y a
parce que c'était une femme encore.
Non, pas parce que c'était une femme,
parce que c'était une start-up
industrielle. vraiment parce que les les
start-up industriels quand on commence à
développer parce que ce que je disais
quand on développe quelque chose ça part
mais parce que les entreprises euh les
start-up industrielles françaises quand
elles commencent à avoir besoin de plus
d'argent d'avoir des investissements
plus lourds sur la la de la de la de la
pr l'industri préindustrialisation
l'industrialisation commencer sur des
petites séries, elle ne trouve pas les
moyens parce que l'investissement dans
l'industrie c'est forcément un temps
plus long que les capex après quand on
passe à échelle sont plus lourds et donc
on n pas envie envie de prendre de
prendre ce risque. Et donc nos boîtes
innovantes, soit elles crèvent avant
d'avoir réussi à montrer à l'échelle de
quoi elles étaient capables, soit elles
se font racheter par des entreprises
étrangères.
Alors, je totalement de mauvaise fois,
il y a des choses qui commencent à être
faites. Je pense que BPI commence à
prendre un peu conscience de ça
maintenant. Oui. Non, mais voilà, on
prend un peu conscience en 2021, c'est
presque 2022. Euh,
on va prendre conscience qu'on est mort,
c'est ça ?
Non, on n'est pas mort. on va y arriver
parce qu'on a on a capable d'avoir
beaucoup d'idées, de se régénérer et que
les il y a plein d'autres innovations
qui vont se créer qu'on a des on a aussi
des gens qui qui on a beau plus en plus
de gens euh qui ont envie que les choses
bougent. Donc je pense qu'il faut rester
optimiste. Maintenant, il y a aussi un
autre truc parce que moi on me dit oui,
il faut pas opposer start-up nation et
industrie.
Alors déjà, on a eu tout un discours où
on parlait que de startup nation, on
parlait pas d'industrie. Heureusement,
il y a eu les gilets jaunes.
Heureusement, il y a eu une crise
mondiale et tout le monde s'est mis à
parler d'industrie.
Heureusement qu'il y a eu les gilets
jaunes.
Les gilets jaunes, ça a été le constat
de la fracture territoriale. Et quel
était le meilleur moyen de recréer de la
cohésion territoriale ? c'était d'aller
implanter des usines dans dans
revasculer
revasculariser le territoire avec
recréer de la valeur dans les
territoires, la réimplanter,
reterritorialiser la valeur,
reterritorialiser les activités et le
faire sur des avec des écosystèmes
puissants, c'està-dire aussi s'appuyer
sur les les ressources locales et on les
on les oppose. Le problème de la
start-up nation, c'est pas la start-up
nation, c'est que la start-up nation,
elle a nié tout un p de notre histoire.
Elle a pas été capable et c'est là qu'on
parle aussi d'imaginaire. L'imaginaire,
c'est quand vous êtes capable de faire
se relier notre héritage avec notre
futur, que vous êtes capable de faire se
relier les gens qui bénéficient de la
mondialisation et ceux qui ont
l'impression d'être d'avoir été les
laissés euh pour compte. C'est ça
l'imaginaire. C'est quand vous faites un
aujourd'hui quand vous faites un poitier
un poitier Marseille et que vous passez
par la corniche des Sévenes et cetera,
vous dites "Mais c'est quoi l'expérience
commune entre quelqu'un qui habite à
Amende et quelqu'un qui habite à Paris ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont en commun ? Comment
est-ce qu'on refait nation ? C'est tout
ça qu'il faut aller. Il faut aller
chercher et l'industrie parce que
l'industrie aussi c'est des grands
projets, c'est une capacité de nation à
se projeter. On a quand même un pays qui
a fait le Concorde, qui fait l'Airbus,
qui a fait la caravelle, le TGV, les
centrales nucléaires, même si on peut
critiquer le nucléaire, on a quand même
fait ça. On a été capable d'inventer
les sous-marins. Non,
les sous-marins aussi. Les sous-marins.
Mais alors les sous-marins parce
qu'après on va parler de l'Australie,
donc on va revenir sur les sujets
d'intelligence économique.
On a été soft. Et pourtant pourtant on
est des bruts
Oui. Mais alors sur l'intelligence
économique il y a il y a des il y a des
des je vous avez passion mais vous avez
déjà invité Christian Arbulot, vous avez
invité les stars du du domaine.
Non mais Christian Arbuo c'est c'est une
star du domaine mais on on connaît
encore plus balaise que Christian
Orbulot
mais on en discutera plus tard.
Je vous ai coupé et j'ai perdu mon fil.
Moi alors j'étais sur l'imaginaire. Je
dis dans un délire l'imaginaire
l'industrie, les usines recréer mais en
fait l'industrie c'est aussi recréer des
rêves communs et les rêves les les
grands rêves ne vont pas pouvoir être
les mêmes.
ou peut-être peut-être que le créer en
tout cas des des objets qui vont nous
permettre d'assurer la transition
écologique, ça doit faire partie des
grands rêves et et il faut le rêve ser
quelque chose d'assez naïf, d'assez
peut-être en enfantin, mais une société
qui ne rêve plus et pour moi une société
qui meurt. Et aujourd'hui, on est une
société qui meurt. On est une société
qui est très technique. On est on est
une société qui est très silotée, on le
voit. On a euh soit par grand corps
d'état, soit on a besoin de déciloter.
On a besoin que des gens qui ne se
parlent pas d'habitude se mettent à
travailler ensemble. On a besoin que des
entreprises de secteur qui ne
travaillaient pas ensemble aillent
travailleraient ensemble.
On a besoin de tout le monde. Dire c'est
pas les énars qu'on peut rester ceux de
la terre. On a tout le monde a un rôle à
jouer. Mais c'est pas que une partie que
qu'une formation qui peut dicter le
destin de tous les autres parce que tout
le monde détient une part de
l'intelligence collective.
Question internet qui est d'ailleurs
sous-entendu
sur l'Europe. Comment fait-elle pour
mettre 28 pays d'accord sur le même
sujet ?
27. Et bien, elle n'y arrive pas parce
que vous avez 27 souverainetés
nationales et vous n'avez pas une
souveraineté européenne. Vous n'avez pas
des gens qui vous disent qu'il y a une
souveraineté européenne. C'est faux. On
a éventuellement délégué certaines parts
de notre souveraineté, certains atouts
tributent notre souveraineté à l'échelle
européenne. Mais le principe même de la
souveraineté, c'est de se dire qu'on
peut redevenir souverain si on peut les
récupérer. Et normalement, comme on peut
sortir de l'Union européenne, donc il
n'y a pas de souveraineté européenne. Et
l'Europe, elle arrive à faire les à
faire s'entendre les États sur c sur les
sujets sur lesquell a une compétence
exclusive, mais elle n'arrive pas à les
faire s'entendre ou à minima sur les
autres sujets.
parce que vous avez 27 intérêts
divergents, parce que vous avez des
histoires nationales divergentes, parce
que l'Europe et c'est important de le
dire, l'Europe c'est les États, la
Commission européenne ce sont des
représentants des États-membres et
beaucoup de décisions qui se passent
sont prises par les Étatsmembres. Et
donc chacun
veut tirer, c'est comment dire ? Si si
on veut aller plus, si on veut vraiment
avoir des européennes, alors il va
falloir accepter d'aller vers soin. Si
on veut miser sur l'Europe, falloir
aller vers du fédéralisme. Et donc il va
falloir accepter de de de détricoter
beaucoup plus les États-nations que nous
l'avons fait aujourd'hui avec le le le
SU européen. C'est le seul moyen
d'arriver à parler à 27. Vous regardez
bien
détricoter les États-nations alors que
on rentre dans une ère où où il y a un
repli identitaire où il y a un repris
idéologique.
Je pense que quand je dis ça, je me fais
insulter par 250 personnes.
En général, ils sont relativement poli
Non mais pas forcément pas forcément
ceux qui nous écoutent maintenant mais
dans d'autres cadres. Euh bien sûr,
parce que la tentation du repli, elle
est elle est elle est elle est elle est
facile parce que parce que ce
la nation c'est quelque chose de de très
fort. L'appartenance nationale,
c'est quelque chose de de très fort.
D'ailleurs, ce qu'on oublie de dire,
c'est quand des gens migrent d'un pays,
ils abandonnent
ils abandonnent le à à contre-cœur, ils
abandonnent quelque chose qui vous
anime. dire, je c'est c'est peut-être
nationaliste, très couillon ce que je
vais dire, mais moi quand je suis à
l'étranger, une des choses qui m'aime le
plus, c'est d'entendre l'hymne de mon
pays et mon drapeau. Alors, je vous ai
dit que je me sentais quand même assez
européenne, mais
c'est c'est c'est votre pays, ça fait
aussi partie de votre identité et de
votre chair. Et donc l'idée d'aller sur
un une instance
plus aller plus loin dans le
fédéralisme, ça va être aussi renoncé à
des attribut à à à à des questions
d'identité qui sont fortes et qui ont
mis des siècles à sédimenter. Ça va être
très compliqué ça. C'est c'est voir
impossible. Mais quand je vois ce qui se
passe à l'échelle européenne, on parle
d'hydrogène mais on va avoir 27 plans
hydrogène et la Chine va mettre combien
? Donc à un moment il va falloir au
moins se forcer. Je sais pas, peut-être
que les citoyens peuvent arriver à à
forcer. Je il y a il y a il y a
peut-être quelque quelque chose à faire.
J'ai pas la réponse, hein. J'en parle
euh en toute humilité parce que je pense
que le le c'est le bon échelon. Mais il
va falloir se forcer à envisager des
taxes carbone aux frontières ensemble.
Il va falloir s' envisager ensemble
comment on construit des grands
programmes européens sur le domaine de
l'hydrogène parce que c'est
mutualisation de moyens humain,
mutualisation de moyens financiers et
que seul semi-conducteur hein, je
reviens sur les semi-conducteurs, Corée
du Sud, elle a annoncé mettre 450
milliards sur la table, on met 6
milliards.
6 milliards, c'est même pas le prix
d'une usine,
c'est petits bras.
C'est petits bras. Et donc il y a il y a
des chos
est-ce qu'on a Est-ce qu'on peut mettre
plus ? Parce que la France n'est pas
devenue une puissance de moyenne
impuissance quand je quand François
Fillon dit "Je suis premier ministre
d'un pays en failli t"
C'est peut-être pour ça non ? Ou ou ou
ça c'est peut-être une forfaiture.
Non mais vous pouvez aussi dire ben je
fais pas 10 projets, j'en fais que cinq
et donc je mets plus sur chaque projet.
Vous pouvez aussi dire
vous pouvez aussi dire c'est l'avenir
c'est peut-être pas l'avenir de
l'humanité mais c'est l'avenir de mes
concitoyens. Et euh est-ce que euh
donner on est capable on a été capable
de s'endetter hein pour faire tenir
l'économie pour pour le dans le cas des
plans de relance ? Est-ce que la
question environnementale
ne justifie pas qu'on mette les mêmes
efforts sur la table ?
On parlait d'intelligence économique et
j'ai un peu perrouré. Je voudrais je
voudrais passer un bonjour. C'est on
s'intéresse beaucoup à l'intelligence
économique grâce à Bernard Zambert
qu'on connaît et on voudrait rendre un
hommage
à Robert Guillaume avec qui on a on a
bossé un peu et qu'on a connu
qui était un chic type et qui était un
des pionniers dans l'intelligence
économique et euh il nous manque
beaucoup et c'était vraiment un gars
super bien. On va prendre une question
internet.
Donc on a fait le le CICE, on a fait les
les 27 pays.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle pense de la future
privatisation d'ADP ?
Je je vais vous dire de manière très
simple. Je pense que c'est alors j'ai un
j'ai pas étudié le le sujet mais le
prime intuition c'est une erreur de la
même manière que en fait on n pas
vraiment la on pourrait se questionner
sur la stratégie de l'agence des
participations d'État et la vision
stratégique qu'on a.
sur le sujet et comment on gère nos
participations. On peut l'impression que
parfois on se sous des des sujets de de
libéralisme économique et cetera, on se
départ un peu de nos atouts et à chaque
fois qu'on l'a fait, ça n'a pas
forcément amélioré une meilleure qualité
pour l'usager. Ce qui m'intéresse c'est
et et d'ailleurs ce qui me fait penser
sur je reviens sur la question d'avant
sur est-ce qu'on a pas les moyens, on a
un des pays qui a la dépense publique la
plus élevée du monde. Donc on se donne
les moyens. Par contre, on a des
services publics qui se dégradent. On a
des gens qui qui travaillent que ça soit
dans le domaine de la police, de
l'école, de la santé, donc les domaines
régaliens qui sont dans une situation de
mal-être pas possible parce que on
narrête pas de leur mettre des
contraintes administratives et qu'au
final ils font plus de temps à
l'université, vous regardez les maîtres
de conférence he ils passent plus de
temps à faire l'administratif qu'à faire
ce qui les passionne. Pourquoi ils sont
là enseignés et faire de la recherche.
Donc il y a il y a peut-être aussi des
moyens à dégager en recherchant un
meilleur fonctionnement qui va
satisfaire et les usagers et les gens
qui travaillent là-dedans.
dans le dans le dans la meilleure
utilisation de notre dépenses publiques.
Question d'internet qui d'ailleurs à mon
avis touche à l'éducation. Ne faut-il
pas plus mettre plus de plus en valeur
les filières et pack pro et technologie
pour former des techniciens et des
ingénieurs avec des vraies compétences
techniques plutôt que la multitude
d'ingénieurs issus de classe prépa qui
suivent un cursus très généraliste et ne
sont que très peu familiers avec le
milieu de l'industrie et de la technique
?
200 fois. Oui. Et une autre chose que je
voudrais dire là-dessus qu'on a pas
abordé, il y a une des différences dans
les il y a deux choses qui différencient
très fortement les entreprises
allemandes des entreprises françaises.
un la participation des salariés dans
les conseils d'administration qui est
beaucoup plus importante que en France
et deux c'est le cursus des dirigeants
allemand des entreprises donc beaucoup
plus familiales mais aussi des gens qui
viennent qui ont commencé par
l'apprentissage et qui ont pu gravir les
échons d'entreprise et qui ont aussi une
vraie légitimité à l'égard de leurs
équipes parce qu'ils connaissent la
réalité du terrain alors que nous on a
beaucoup de gens qui viennent de grandes
écoles ENA école de commerce et cetera
et qui ne sont pas forcément vu comme
légitime et qui n'ont pas forcément la
connaissance technique et il y a des
choses à avoir dans les dans les
parcours et revaloriser les finières
techniques, ça devient de plus en plus
rare hein, de voir des gens qui rentrent
euh, on va dire, par la petite porte
dans une entreprise et qui en finissent
directeur général ou ou PDG ou même
membre du comité de direction. Donc, il
faut valoriser ces filières et il faut
aussi, je pense, ouvrir les usines,
c'est-à-dire très tôt aller montrer
au aux collégiens, aux lycéens et et pas
à mon avis pas qu'à eux. parce que ils
ont parfois leurs parents qui
travaillent dans les usines mais à leurs
enseignants qui sont les premiers à
avoir des discours délétaires sur
l'usine. Il y a encore des gens qui
disent si tu es pas bon tu vas finir à
l'usine. Vous imaginez l'image et puis
l'image pour les enfants dont les
parents travaillent dans une usine
on dirait qu'il travaillent au bagne.
C'est dévalorisant et c'est
condescendant possible. Donc il faut
remontrer un pour que les citoyens qui
habitent à proximité des usines voient
ce qu'elles sont et deux pour montrer
que l'industrie, il y a encore he des
eau là mais c'est plus la la majorité et
que il y a il y a il y a des des très
belles choses à faire, très belles
carrières et des rémunérations aussi qui
souvent sont sensiblement plus hautes
que dans d'autres secteurs, notamment la
logistique.
Question que je vais reformuler un peu.
Le protectionnisme, on fait, on fait
pas, c'est important, c'est pas
important.
Alors moi, j'aime pas du tout le mot
protectionnisme
parce que parce que ça renvoie toujours
un imaginaire de nationalistes, de gens
qui veulent se replier sur eux. Par
contre, je pense qu'il faut pas être
tourte, c'est-à-dire les autres font du
protectionnisme ou subventionnent la
Chine, elle donne des aides à à ces
entreprise, elle ou elle est actionnaire
d'un certain nombre d'entreprises. La
Chine, elle a été capable de fermer ses
marchés pour permettre de faire émerger
des géants comme Huawei et et d'autres.
et les États-Unis sont en train de de
faire la même chose. Donc on exige de
nos envir de nos entreprises de haut
standards environnementaux et bien
obligeons la même chose pour les
produits qui veulent rentrer.
Question est-ce qu'il faut poser tout
types de questions. La
réindustrialisation est-elle compatible
avec une baisse de l'immigration,
c'est-à-dire avec moins de main d'œuvre
à bas prix ?
Je suis pas sûr de comprendre exactement
la question. Une baisse de migration.
Alors, il y a il y a il y a il y a une
légende qui dit qui est surtout
véhiculée par l'extrême droite que on a
fait énormément d'immigration pour faire
baisser les salaires et que ça
arrangeait les patrons de bois de
l'industrie parce que ça faisait de la
main d'œuvre pas cher dans le bâtiment
et dans tout ça.
Oui. Alors ça c'est surtout aussi
peut-être les directives européennes et
la législation européenne qui permet
d'avoir certains enfin sur les
phénomènes de dumping social d'avoir des
gens qui sont sur contrat de leur dans
leur pays et qui viennent en Europe sur
les contrats de leur pays donc sur des
des en France sur donc sur des standards
moins haut. Après euh l'immigration
bah et un moment j'ai pas très très
envie d'être provoque. Alors parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a une situation de
chômage en France. C'est assez paradoxal
hein parce qu'on a beaucoup de demandes
d'emploi enfin beaucoup d'offres
d'emploi et un chômage qui reste assez
fort. Mais comme il y a un certain
nombre de compétences qu'on a plus
notamment dans le domaine du textile,
c'est très difficile de trouver
certaines compétences de couturièr et
cetera et bien il va peut-être falloir
même aller chercher des gens à
l'étranger.
Une culotte sur 500 est fait est fait en
France. H on arrive à la fin de notre
émission, il y a énormément de questions
qui
euh là il y a encore 208 nouveaux
messages
on arrive plus à suivre. Est-ce que vous
avez trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté ?
Alors n'importe lesquels, hein,
c'est n'importe n'importequel. Des
livres qui vous ont influencés, des
livres qui sont vos livres de chevet.
Alors euh
des livres pour l'avenir des
premier un premier livre qui n'a rien à
voir avec l'industrie.
C'est un auteur plutôt, il s'appelle Ala
Elas. C'est un auteur égyptien. Il a
écrit notamment l'immeuble Yakubian et
bien d'autres. L'immeuble Yakouban, très
connu parce que ça fait un film.
Pourquoi je donne ce nom ? J'aurais pu
en donner 10000 autres. J'aurais pu
donner des auteurs japonais. J'aurais pu
donner des auteurs israéliens parce que
je crois que pour il n'y a rien de mieux
que la littérature étrangère pour
comprendre l'autre, comprendre la
manière dont il raisonne, comprendre sa
culture. Et quand on comprend la culture
de l'autre, on comprend aussi ce qui
fait les forces et notamment les forces
de son industrie. Et on a besoin de se
nourrir des autres aussi pour grandir.
Je dis pas qu'il faut les copier, mais
il faut les comprendre et il faut
comprendre ce qu'il peut faire leur
force. Et c'est un des auteurs qui,
pourquoi je le cite lui ? parce que
c'est un des auteurs qui arrivent le
mieux à nous faire nous projeter dans
l'Égypte moderne ou plus ancienne qui
s'est recréé tout cet univers d'image
qui a aussi été un résistant face à la
situation en Égypte et donc c'est un des
auteurs que je conseillerais.
Vous connaissez l'Égypte ?
Euh non, très peu en plus. Mais euh
est-ce que je peux compléter est-ce que
je peux amer votre réponse ? Allez-y.
C'est très bien de s'intéresser à la
littérature étrangère et aux ouvrages
étrangers et c'est encore mieux de le
lire dans la langue dans le dans
lesquelles ou dans lequel il a été
écrit.
Ça permet de comprendre vraiment les
ramifications et les racines du texte.
Excusez-moi.
Non, mais je vous en prie, vous avez
raison. Les subtilités qui sont pas
forcément faciles à traduire en dans
notre langue à nous. Le deuxième conseil
de lecture, c'est Noam Schomski euh pour
reprendre le contrôle de nos vies.
Euh troisème conseil que je donnerai,
c'est quelque chose qui s'appelle la
guerre hors limite. C'est deux généraux
chinois. C'est Kyo Kyolang, je crois et
j'ai oublié le nom, mais bon, la guerre
hor limite, on trouve très bien pour
comprendre la philosophie chinoise et
notamment euh comment ils perçoivent le
monde. Et vous meerez un 4e peut-être
conseil de lecture, c'est Serge Audier,
la trilogie qu'il a fait sur la question
de l'environnement et du productivisme.
Alors, c'est très ardu
en tout cas, je pense qu'il y a aussi
des choses intéressantes à aller chez
lui, à lire chez lui. Est-ce que Est-ce
que vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ? Je suis désolé de demander
ça. Euh un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose d'impérissable.
Euh
un conseil,
un c'est c'est très dur. J'ai des
conseils tarte à la crème qui me
viennent.
Euh un vrai conseil, c'est être vrai,
c'est être sincère.
Faut pas et être humble, faut pas
prendre les gens de haut. Il y a des
gens qui s'expriment pas, qui ne
maîtrisent pas forcément la langue,
disent pas les choses de la même
manière, parfois de malade droite. Mais
être sincère, il faut faire les choses
avec sincérité et avec beaucoup
d'humilité. Et peut-être si je pouvais
en rajouter un parce que ça c'est
quelque chose que j'ai beaucoup dit à
mes étudiants, ne croyez jamais les gens
qui vous dit qui vous diront vous n'y
arriverez pas, c'est pas fait pour toi.
Parce que les gens qui ont réussi la
vérité, c'est qu'ils se sont cassés la
gueule 36000 fois. et qu'on ne réussit
pas sans échouer et que si on a décidé
de faire quelque chose, on peut le faire
malgré l'adversité, malgré beaucoup de
choses. Voilà, si je veux des conseils,
peut-être ter à la crème, peut-être mais
en tout cas c'est des conseils auxquels
je crois et que je dis avec sincérité.
Anaïs Voilis, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]